with that I sincerely apologize that I
can't stay and answer questions I'm
doing my committee for executive session
about five minutes ago but I felt like
it was really important for me to come
here and introduce this bill to how I
came to this movement and why I feel
like this is so important any questions
can be directed to my expert Sam
fieldman and my colleague Ellen Reed is
going to be here as well
um thank you so much for your time and
consideration
thank you representative understand
about two places at the same time
so I won't ask any questions of you and
we'll let you carry thank you for being
here and thank you for introducing the
measure
okay we have a uh a little bit of a
tradition of trying to do uh as a
courtesy
recognizing Representatives who are here
I see representative Reed is here but I
do not or I she was just here okay okay
and she does have a pink sheet
pink card
okay
uh
we do have Sam Phelan back in the house
uh Sam we'd like to welcome you back to
State Federal
thank you uh the last time that we spoke
I went into some detail about the
various protections over the Article 5
convention process that uh you see from
the from the States from the courts and
from um and from the uh the Congress as
well uh this bill is specifically
um to deal with the protections that the
states have over the process
um and we've seen in uh numerous
instances in various processes including
within the Constitution including
several types of constitutional
conventions
um States having direct control over
their delegates we saw that as I
mentioned last time
um in states with control over the
article 7 over their delegates to
article seven conventions that ratified
the US Constitution we saw that as the
story I told played a huge role here in
New Hampshire but it was also in play
um in about half of the other states
that ratified the US Constitution and
Connecticut and uh
quite several others um
the the and uh in addition when the time
came for the use of the other convention
type under Article 5 the Article 5
ratifying convention uh nearly every
state I think all but maybe two of them
had some sort of language that limited
their delegates uh to the will of the
people
um
and that same type of language is what
led to this kind of Bill here we've seen
about a dozen states or so across the
U.S past similar
um similar bills in the last few years
and there's been an increased activity
in that specifically since 2020 won the
case of CIO follow V Washington came
down unanimously from the Supreme Court
upholding exactly the type of delegate
protection language that is in both this
which goes deep into specifically the
Article 5 Convention as well as the same
language that's in reporchella's bill
that goes broadly in all different types
of Interstate conventions
um the biggest point of contention in uh
in different bills generally there's a
very broad agreement of this set of
principles that should be in these bills
it's very broadly bipartisan of what the
different protections are that one
should have the biggest point of
contention is generally whether
delegates should be elected or appointed
it is my opinion and and I spoke to rep
uh rep Newell about this and she also
agrees uh that it's better for delegates
to be elected than appointed indeed both
are possible
um other Interstate conventions have
delegates that are appointed but uh
nearly every convention that has
occurred under the U.S Constitution had
delegates that were elected that's the
article article 7 ratifying conventions
all of the states had their elect had
their delegates elected
and in fact they opened up the Democracy
more than they typically would and and
didn't limit it to just property holders
it was still you know racist and sexist
but at least the property holder
restriction was was lifted in quite a
few states to allow the process to be
more open to the public in Massachusetts
there was so much demand for uh for
attention over this process that was so
open that they could and hold it in the
state house because it wasn't big enough
for all the people who wanted to come
and watch they had to use the largest
building in the in the state of
Massachusetts at the time in order to
hold the the convention there so that
people could see and participate and
that pretty well characterized
um the level of interest and openness
that people had over this process and
among the reasons why elections are are
so helpful here
when you have a whole bunch of people
who are very interested in a single
issue that tends to help give the
elections an additional layer of
security that they don't always have
when you're dealing with Congressional
elections or other elections where
there's multiple issues at play people
who are paying attention and have strong
opinions on one particular issue their
vote tends to much better reflect the
actual views of the public rather than
when you have wedge issues and divisive
topics and things like that in play and
the election process and that's why this
Bill calls for the use of Elections for
that this bill also follows the the
language that's already in the existing
state law here in New Hampshire
surrounding your own State
constitutional conventions indeed it
takes the the section of your of the New
Hampshire code and just builds right
onto that to add in addition the two
other types of conventions in which New
Hampshire May participate both the state
ratifying conventions which New
Hampshire has previously had a law about
back in 1933 as well as the Article 5
proposing convention
um
and the yeah the other protections that
it builds in it adds penalties but it
only adds criminal penalties in the very
specific circumstance where somebody is
intentionally trying to use this process
uh to overthrow our government this is
something that there is no reason to
believe is possible to do successfully
for all of the reasons that I've said
before but we thought that it made sense
for the attempt to do so to have some
additional penalty even though there's
no possibility that it would actually be
successful that would be Insurrection I
believe under the 14th Amendment and so
it calls for the penalty that that is
there for Insurrection under the 14th
Amendment which is to be barred from
public office uh to give you an example
of what kinds of things do or or would
or would not qualify we saw a case in
Florida in 2008 that I mentioned last
time Ford V Browning where there were
delegates who had an uh to a limited
state State Convention there who had an
honest disagreement about what their
limitations were if that were the case
here those delegates would see their
votes invalid and they would see
themselves replaced but the disagreement
was clearly honest there'd be no chance
of any criminal penalties there you
would have to prove Beyond a reasonable
doubt that people had the intention to
not only violate their oath but also to
do so in a way that was specifically
intended to overthrow the federal
government so it just adds that extra
level of protection that we've not seen
in other similar bills basically
everything else that's in here is in
various similar bills and the language
is very similar to the language that's
already in your your code for State
conventions as well as similar to the
language that's in uh repercelli's bill
that's intended to apply more broadly
across different types of of Interstate
meetings and with that I'm happy to take
any questions
say thank you Sam so this language is
rolling or proposed language rules into
irsa 667 colon one which is existing
statute so I'm looking at the proposed
language there's a lot of language
some of it uh amends some gender type uh
issues which which is understandable
having put a a bill in before that
changed one word
um and that was a chore when there's
this many words or phrases or things it
we're going to need to look at all this
of course that's our job
um but I I want to ask you uh this this
afternoon we're going to have an
executive session on HB 269
relative to limiting The Authority of
New Hampshire delegates to policy making
conventions now that is related it looks
to me like it's related to what's the
intent of this bill is
uh it looks so my question is
are you are you familiar with 269 that
we're going to be looking at and I
testified and supported that one as well
that's what I thought so
uh could you explain to us the the
difference in intent between 269 which
we're going to exec this afternoon and
uh 392 which we just heard introduced
sure
um the 269 is intended to be Ezra
Porcelli indicated that one is intended
to be more Broad and this one is
intended to be more deep uh Bill 269 is
intended to apply to all types of
Interstate policy making conventions
whereas this um specifically deals with
the Article Five the two types of
conventions in Article Five both the
proposing and the ratifying conventions
there is a slight overlap because the
Article 5 proposing convention is both
um and in that case I spoke to Red
Porcelli and there's only one point
where the two bills disagree which is
the method of choosing delegates and
alternates uh her Bill calls for them to
be done by appointment which makes sense
for all types of interstate compacts
with the exception of the article 5
proposing convention
um because in in general that's the way
it has been for all other all types of
interstate compacts other than ones
within the cost institution itself
and she is all right with I I mean I
don't want to speak for her but my
understanding is that she's all right
with this bill superseding hers uh in
that one area where they conflict where
this one calls for the election of those
uh same uh same representatives and
delegates
right so you just pointed out one area
where you use the Expression conflict
and that that's what I'm trying to get
to is is is there a conflict between 392
and two in 269 both of which it sounds
like you you approved I do or support
you've testified for both of them
so the area of conflict uh we need to
drill down on that over the next few
days before we exec on this but you'd
have to do it now we have some other
folks who'd like to speak but if if you
could uh for me or for us uh if you
wouldn't mind having testified in both
of these if you could address the what
you just pointed out as a conflict
between the two measures so that we can
try to reconcile that if you could maybe
shoot an email at some point yeah
absolutely uh yeah and I've spoken to
both Representatives Newell and
representative Porcelli and my
understanding is that they're uh they're
both all right with uh this bill
superseding the other one in that one
narrow area of Elections versus
appointments specifically for the
Article 5 proposing convention so if
reportcelli's Bill is the only one that
passes it would stand if they both pass
then on that one point of law this one
would supersede that
thank you because we're gonna have to
reconcile that difference I we I don't
see this committee recommending passage
of two different measures that where
there's a conflict between two of them
between wording so that's what we need
to address and yeah I would I would
suggest an amendment something to the
effect of
um notwithstanding something in section
the the one that is referenced in uh in
the other Bill to the contrary
this that I I would recommend an
amendment to this bill that says
something to that effect
right so if you could uh and it's up to
you if you want to address that
um that would help us to try to
reconcile that because you obviously
have some some great background in this
area
so uh thank you for that from wolf pack
pack being Pac quite other questions for
Miss fieldman uh representative
Charlotte
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
being with us again today
um I think you mentioned in your
testimony that article 7 said ratified
and delegates could either be elected or
appointed it doesn't specify a in
article 7 how the the delegates are to
be chosen uh the different states all
um past laws for how that would happen
and I believe all of them I I might be
mistaken but I believe all of them went
with elections for the article 7
ratifying conventions Mr chair sure a
follow-up
um but doesn't the Constitution say
there's another means of ratifying an
amendment that being the state
legislature uh isn't that the tradition
in this state that at the legislature
that will vote on ratification and not a
separate ratifying group sure uh article
7 was specifically to ratify the U.S
Constitution itself that's a separate
provision from the provision for
ratifying amendments for ratifying
amendments that's a type of convention
that's in Article 5 itself and 26 of the
27 Amendments that we have were ratified
by the state legislatures which is one
of the two procedures in Article 5 for
ratification station the other procedure
was used only once for the 20 uh 21st
Amendment
um and you know people at the time were
worried because nobody had ever had an
article 5 convention before in this
country
um but the the supporters really wanted
an article 5 convention they pushed real
hard for Article 5 ratifying conventions
and Congress ultimately proposed that we
ratify it with Article 5 proposing
conventions which is their right to do
under our under Article Five
um and even without
um bills in place in the states for how
to limit their delegates all of the
states were able to figure out and they
were able to figure it out very quickly
what this bill does is prevent the the
difficulties that the states faced at
that time where they had to ratify where
they had to propose new laws and all
figured out from scratch very quickly
this allows us to have in place the gold
standard for what that language should
look like ahead of time so whether you
support or oppose the use of the article
5 convention process I think we can all
agree that it's better to have language
in place ahead of time uh in in case
there is an article 5 convention whether
you want there to be one or not so that
we know what that process will look like
and in fact I gave you a letter from uh
then sender now President Joe Biden
supporting a similar type of measure in
the U.S Senate I passed the the Senate
unanimously in this form and was
supported by people like Chuck Schumer
and Mitch McConnell in addition to Joe
Biden um
in fact Chuck Schumer was one of the
main authors of the report that uh that
uh Joe Biden wrote the letter on
um and uh that just was intended to uh
in in Joe Biden's letter you can see
even though he didn't support the use of
the convention process himself and I
think he was mistaken on that he still
supported this type of Regulation over
the process so that there would be more
certainty in it thank you
oh as I've pointed out we are going to
exec 269 this afternoon and don't know
how that's going to go until we actually
vote on it and discuss it in an
executive session if it does pass again
to my earlier concern you know if if
this is turns out to be a good measure
that that people want to support uh
we're going to need need some help to
reconcile some language here so that
this can get Fair consideration in a
week from today when we exact
um 392. uh 21st amendment was
Prohibition repeal correct yes so that's
that's the only amendment that has been
ratified in a different process real
real quick could you just speak to that
why that amendment ratification was
different uh yeah the activists involved
didn't want to send back to the States
an amendment to repeal uh an amendment
that the states had not that long before
voted to ratify
um so there was a lot of concern over
the process there were also people who
were pushing for the use of the article
5 convention process to propose it for a
similar reason because they were worried
that Congress had just proposed an
amendment and would be hard-pressed for
Congress to uh to overturn it and it
took a Monumental movement in this
country uh there's a great organization
women's Organization for national
prohibition reform among other efforts
um that uh that helped turned around
Congress
um along with of course the Great
Depression which was the huge triggering
event helped turn around Congress
um but part of the the deal that they
made with those coalitions was not to
put the states in a position to change
the views that they had just had in
their state legislatures but rather to
let the people directly decide and they
knew it was a big deal there was
fear-mongering at the time in fact the
first one to spread convention fears
broadly and in a way that was false was
Wayne Wheeler who's one of the most
famous propagandists in the country and
he was spreading fears of an article 5
convention
um way back then
um and um
but they happened and it was they knew
it was a big deal at the time the state
of Utah even called in uh a national
radio broadcast they were the last state
to hold their convention and they
delayed ratification to call in a
national radio broadcast which in 1933
was very difficult and actually have a
picture of the article 5 convention in
Utah when they ratified there that's a
very thorough answer and I love the
history and uh would love to stay with
that but we need to roll on here any any
other questions for Mr Sam fieldman
uh sure
so my understanding is this what is
different about this bill is it proposed
the delegates be elected and one of the
themes I've heard underlying themes of
all of these bills for Article 5
conventions is the concern about money
in politics so in having elected
delegates how do you control
the money that's behind it that's the
the great thing about a single issue
election and in particular the
convention that wolf pack is pushing for
a convention that deals specifically
with the issue of money in politics has
an extra added protection that the
others do not
um but in any type of single issue
single issue election uh the influence
of money is smaller and in an election
where the single issue is the corrupting
influence of money in politics itself uh
then this spending large amounts of
money in the election can sometimes even
hurt rather than help and we've seen
that in elections on both sides of the
aisle we saw that when Benjamin Brad
beat Eric Cantor we saw that when
Alexandria ocasio-cortez beat Joseph
Crowley we saw that just recently in the
New Jersey uh State Senate when um when
um an unknown truck driver at Durr beat
the the uh president of the Senate uh
Sweeney
um when when the issue was in politics
it ends up being counter effective but
some degree of that protection is in
place whenever you have a
well-publicized which this would
certainly be election especially limited
to a single issue
okay thank you Sam we need to roll on I
do before I lose you I do want to point
out which I've already mentioned uh
before uh I or we are very interested in
trying to reconcile these two measures
you're a duty expert
so the the prime sponsor could not be
here the co-sponsor representative Reed
is here so I would encourage you and
representative Reed reps of Newell uh as
soon as you have time to do this uh send
me or send us uh some you mentioned an
amendment so that may be required I will
give that to you before the executive
session today uh before when before the
executive session today okay okay I was
going to say Anytime by Monday or
Tuesday but uh if I well I will try to
get it to you before the executive
session today if I'm unable certainly by
Monday or Tuesday oh sure all right well
thank you thank you very much okay we
have uh Eric benvenida says Eric here uh
Eric welcome
supporting the bill asked for three
minutes yep yep I'll try not to go more
with that as much as I can um and thank
you um Mr chairman thank you members of
the committee I always love coming here
and testifying and I I thank you for
your service to the citizens of New
Hampshire
um on sitting these committees uh my
name is Eric Benavides as the chairman
said
um I am resident of Guilford New
Hampshire
um and I'm here in support of HB 392
um
for the last seven years I volunteer
with a group called wolf pack
um its goal is an amendment to the U.S
Constitution to address the corrupting
influence of money and politics
um
I was frustrated with the lack of a
representation in our federal government
and the realization that the vast
majority of the bills being passed
directly benefited special interests
pouring money into our elections they
have basically captured every branch of
our government
I began searching for organizations that
were working on this issue and and were
fighting back and wolf pack stood out to
me on all those organizations as having
the most effective and verified method
of getting the change by means of an
article 5 U.S convention uh Convention
of the U.S Constitution
of being a form of a librarian though I
had to do my own research I never take
anything at face value I have to look it
up I have to see the evidence for myself
so after searching through many
peer-reviewed reports on Article 5 and
the State Convention process one common
theme between all of those reports
became clear
that this is a safe process and though
it's never been used it serves as a
check and balance to ensure that it's
limited to one address that is called
and furthermore it has been an effective
proven tool to put pressure on a corrupt
Congress to make change and that is the
17th Amendment we they had no intention
of having direct election of senators
and it took the states pressuring them
through an article 5 convention call to
make them do the right thing and have us
directly elect our Senators so that was
the people power bring pressure now that
being said with all these checks and
balances that we have in the Article 5
convention
um I do believe that this bill should be
supported because any uh amount of Extra
Protection we can put on the process and
any transparency that we can put on the
process on how it's being called how
it's being done I think is a good thing
and puts a lot of people's minds at ease
with this process so that is why I'm
here supporting this bill
um
I feel like we are in a cage of our own
making right now
um that cage is made out of fear
fear of a process that we don't
understand pure process that is unknown
um but that fear is created by the
people that want to keep us in that cage
um it is it is amazing to me that the
one process that we have to put a check
on all three branches of government that
the people can use is somehow the most
dangerous and that we can't use it and I
just don't feel like that is the truth I
feel like
um we can unlock that cage and walk out
we have the method the founders gave us
the method to do that
um and I feel like we are
um negligent in not using it and not
bringing this country back to a
representative Republic that it belongs
um
so finally I'll leave the committee with
a final word urgency
um every day that we do not act our
Democratic Republic slips a little
further away
um every day we allow lobbyists to roam
the halls of the state house or special
interests to drown the voices of average
citizens with money we break our Oaths
and pledges The Pledge I just took this
morning and the old two took of office
we violate that oath every day that we
delay my son is now 15 years old and
every day I fight for him to live in a
country where his voice matters
and that his voice when he turns 18 will
count for something and I hope that you
sitting in this room too are fighting as
well for him
um I again respectfully thank everyone
on this committee for your Devotion to
New Hampshire
um and for hearing my testimony today
and I'll be glad to answer any questions
you have
thank you Mr Benavides did you say do I
understand you correctly that the threat
of an article 5 convention has helped is
what helped prod Congress to pass the
17th Amendment yeah we came within one
state at that time
um of of calling an article 5 convention
and every step of the way uh Congress at
that point said no absolutely not but as
soon as we got to within one state they
changed their mind and then they they
proposed the amendment to directly elect
our Senators
so your point then if I understand you
correctly is that the existence of an
article 5 option uh is what brought
about the traditional adoption of the
17th Amendment is that kind of what
you're saying yeah because the the
before that time senators were directly
elected and it was based it was called
at that time the millionaires Club you
couldn't be a senator without being a
millionaire even back then
um so uh so there was a lot of
corruption involved and they were not
going to change that but they were
pressured to and I think the same thing
you know I'm not a fortune teller I
don't know what's going to happen um but
I feel like if Congress has given the
choice to give up power
or to do the right thing they will
ultimately do the right thing now that
might not be true I have no idea but in
either in either scenario we get what we
want we either get an amendment to fix
the corruption corrupting influence of
money through Congress or we call the
convention and get the amendment
ourselves so either way I feel like it's
to win-win
thank you for that other questions
uh representative Kerry
so in creating delegates to this
convention
I mean ordinarily the people who
represent us in Congress are voted on by
all the voters does creating delegates
to a convention create sort of super
delegates who supersede the rights of
the individual to vote
um I don't believe so because
um the on the state level when we were
point to delegates these delegates are
restricted they're restricted only to
the subject at hand they can't go to the
election and supersede the votes of the
people and even in under current Law
Without these binding resolutions that
are in this bill
um
we are allowed to if someone goes off
the rails and and have done in the past
for other types of conventions we can
recall those delegates so if they're
doing something that we don't uh that
are not representative of the people of
New Hampshire we can recall them and
send other delegates in their place
um so that's the that's the that's what
we have currently what this bill does is
ADD even more protections for the people
of New Hampshire to make sure that those
delegates are in fact you uh carrying
out the will of the New Hampshire
citizens
for the other questions
Cena and thank you so much Mr Benavides
uh Ken Quinn is asked for five minutes
to speak in support of the bill and um
if any of the points that you were going
to make Mr Quinn have been made
you can feel free to not repeat them
we're looking for some some new some new
testimony here thank you for and welcome
back thank you so much Mr chair and
members of the committee I agree I don't
want to repeat anything I've said in my
previous testimony or what you've
already heard I'm just encouraged by
seeing this level of activity to get to
a convention and so I highly support
HP
392 as you know I'm working to get to
such a convention and I've been
testifying now in front of this
committee for close to 10 years and it's
been this fear of how will a convention
play out that has in my opinion from
what I see in here has been what's
stopping us from getting a passage on a
article 5 application
I want to just share
kind of what I've been seeing in those
10 years we really have become a country
of two groups and I'm not talking about
the political parties
we have become
positioned on two sides one side is both
parties trying to work together which we
desperately need to introduce reforms at
the federal level to start fixing the
problems we're facing as a nation that's
the group I belong to
we need to come together on some issues
that we can agree on our country
desperately needs that
the other group
are both sides coming together to stop
and silence the voice of the American
people to stop needed reforms from being
from being introduced those are the two
camps we all fall into today
and I encourage I hope that all of you
here who fall into the group that I
belong to that would like to see some
reforms that are agreed upon by
both sides of the political issue side
that's what we need in fact I want to
use an example the 1787 Federal
convention is typically used as the
example of an article 5 convention well
that's just simply wrong we've heard
that there's never been a convention
before that has proposed amendments that
is simply wrong and I want to set the
record straight
and this is phenomenal history in 1861
the nation was heading to a civil war
Virginia called a convention to propose
amendments to the Constitution to
prevent the war from breaking out
so we have had one of these conventions
the country was divided as you all know
21 states sent Commissioners to
Washington D.C they met in Willard's
Hotel on February 4th they were there
for three weeks
they drafted the rules they appointed
um
I figured the name of the President
Tyler who was the former president
United States as the president of this
convention they drafted several
amendments dealing with the slavery
issue
now because it was not called under
Article Five this is the only difference
because two-thirds of the states did not
apply for it they could not have it
proposed directly to the state so Tyler
walked over to Congress and delivered
the amendments to Congress to have
Congress propose it and then Senate out
for ratification
foreign
the war broke out shortly thereafter and
we know the rest of history but this
process works in fact the rules that we
have seen in many of the conventions
since then are the very rules adopted at
the 1861 was known as the Washington
peace conference and New Hampshire sent
delegates I think one of your delegates
was Amos tuck that's one of the
individuals from from this state
um in fact I want to read to you Maine's
commission this was from commission to
Maine and it deals directly with this
piece of legislation here's the
commission from 1861 and it says this
said Commissioners to be subject at all
times to the control of the legislatures
so right here from history we have
evidence that in a convention that's
proposing an Amendment to the US
Constitution that the Commissioners are
under control of the state legislature
at all times that is what this
resolution before you does you control
them and in order to back up that
control you have some teeth to it which
I like to see I think that's a good idea
lastly
I would like to just add that Justice
Scalia antonine Scalia he he was in
favor of an article 5 convention he was
against a constitutional convention but
he was in favor of an article 5
convention and he figured out and you
can watch this in his own testimony that
he figured out and determined only two
percent of the American people can stop
and Amendment to the US Constitution and
he wanted the stage to have an article 5
convention to actually revise Article 5
to make it easier for the states to
propose amendments and as I was driving
down I was thinking about our Amendment
history
our constitution has been in effect now
for 235 years
we have 27 Amendments 33 have been
proposed so that averages out to 10 and
a half years per amendment when you
count the Bill of Rights being won
because they were proposed at the same
time
so if the average
is 10 and a half years for an amendment
to be proposed
I want to put this out to you
the last time an amendment to the U.S
Constitution has been proposed has been
52 years ago
the Constitution was designed to keep up
with the progress and that's what the
amending provision is for as as progress
changes we need to address that with
reforms that amendment was allowing 18
year olds to vote we have not had an
amendment proposed
since 1971.
now I ask you in the last 52 years has
our society changed
I would say quite drastically
has our constitution kept up with the
progress
I would say not even close
that is what this process allows us to
do Congress refuses to introduce the
needed reforms on many issues that we
need
it's time for the American Voice the
American the voice of the American
people to be heard this is what this
does
in its time and I I highly encourage you
to support this and
if you have any questions I will be here
to take those and I I like the idea of
maybe seeing what needs to be changed so
that one of these can be passed with
that covers what you need I'll take a
look at it as well if I can help and
lastly if you are interested in the
rules of the 21st amendment on how the
states convene these ratifying
conventions uh there's a recommended
Source I can email to the committee it
provides every state and their laws that
they created to hold ratifying
conventions for the 21st amendment thank
you
questions for Mr Quinn uh president of
shirtleff
yeah there's just a brief uh would you
believe you mentioned the name Amos tuck
and it's somewhat ironic that I look out
the window it's the New Hampshire
historical society that Amos tuck gave
to our state so I know I went over there
to get records on that on his his him
being there it's it's phenomenal so
thank you yes great history
anything else from Mr Quinn
uh thank you for your testimony you've
been here several times and as you
pointed out uh this measure uh likely
needs some mending and if I I know the
wolf pack folks uh if you're available
or interested to work with the
co-sponsors that's something that would
be appreciated thank you so much we have
one more pink card I see on this uh
Debbie Augustine
two two more pink cards
hey
um good morning representative Moffett
and members of the committee uh thank
you for the opportunity to speak with
you today my name is Debbie Augustine
and I live in Kentucky New Hampshire I'm
here to ask you to support House Bill
392 relative to Constitutional
Convention procedures for delegates
since I retired in June of 2020 I've
been volunteering with wolf pack
by the time my granddaughter was born 10
years ago I had had it with congress's
Shameless corruption and its allegiance
to their special interest donors and I
realized that it's not okay for congress
people to spend up to 70 percent of
their time fundraising for their next
elections when they should be doing the
people's work
after all our children's democracy
should not belong to the highest bidders
House Bill 392 spells out the regulatory
process for delegates of an article 5
Convention of the U.S Constitution such
a constitution could address campaign
Finance reform by means of a
constitutional amendment
passing this bill will expedite a
state-sled effort to pressure Congress
into dealing with a systemic corruption
entrench in our politics
besides it's a sure bet that Congress
won't be passing its own anti-corruption
any Bill anytime soon
they can't even ban insider trading for
themselves
passing 392 will show we need business
when it comes to business as usual
New Hampshire along with the rest of the
States has the power to pressure
Congress into fixing our badly broken
campaign Finance system but only if we
use it
I thank you for your services
legislators and respectfully urge you to
support this very important legislation
thanks
thank you so much questions for
Augustine
and I thank you again and now we do have
at least one more pink card from one of
the co-sponsors representative Reed
thank you Mr chair and thank you
honorable members of the committee uh
for the record my name is Ellen Reed I
represent New Market and new Fields
Rockingham 10.
um I will keep my uh you have seen for
those of you have been on this committee
for multiple terms you've seen this
issue repeatedly I'm going to keep my
remarks briefed so as not to go into
what other people have said not to go
into what you've surely heard over the
years but
um so I want to address primarily two
arguments against this bill or any other
similar bill that you may have heard and
may hear in the future one and they're
kind of conflicting arguments actually
one is that
Article 5 convention has never happened
this is not something that we need to
address it's probably never going to
happen and the other argument is that
passing something like this would
increase the likelihood of us going to
an article 5 convention and thereby
running the risk of the notorious
runaway convention so the first one is
it going to happen is it likely to
happen my answer is it's coming
um I do a lot of work in polarization
my background has been an election law
despite me being on the fish and game
committee and uh what we've seen from
multiple studies on the national level
is that the polarization we're
experiencing right now in this country
the extreme polarization
um there's people who say it's kind of a
blip or it's like the natural ebb and
flow of democracies it is not it has
increased polarization and divisiveness
has increased over the last many decades
and we are getting to a Tipping Point
in fact there is more and more talk
whereas I know when I was a child or a
young person it would have been
Unthinkable to talk about uh violent
um uprisings in our country and yet
that's become a normal topic of
conversation and I need to point out
that this is not one side both sides of
the political
ideology are furious at our government
are unhappy
and just to quote Jefferson if you would
allow me to quote the Declaration of
Independence
there's only so much that we can take of
that anger before something happens
Prudence indeed will dictate that
governments long established should not
be changed for light and transient
causes and accordingly all experience
hath shown that mankind are more
disposed to suffer while Evils are
sufferable than to write themselves by
abolishing the forms to which they are
accustomed but when a long train of
abuses and usurpations pursuing
invariably the same object events is
designed to reduce them under absolute
despotism it is their right it is their
duty to throw off such government and to
provide new guards for their future
security and that is what we are rapidly
approaching
one of the things that people again on
both sides are looking for to avoid
something like that is an article Vive
convention to reform the government that
they see as oppressive
now how close are we not only are we
increasing in that polarization and
increasing in that unhappiness but as
you know 34 states are required to call
a convention
over the years 400 calls have been made
and we would have already had a
convention had the language lined up had
it happened in in the right time frame
but just currently in the convention of
States push which has gained quite a bit
of momentum they're already up to 19
states that have adopted that particular
language the BBA amendment is already up
to 28 so six states away from calling an
article 5 convention and so my point is
this that we could repeal our current
call and never pass a call New Hampshire
could never pass a call and still be
called into a convention within a few
years so we need a way to handle that
um so
going back to the point about the need
for an article 5 convention
I look at it like medicine while there
are risks to an article 5 uh convention
it's kind of like
being sick being a patient if you're
healthy you're not likely to undergo a
risky procedure or take a medicine that
has severe side effects but when you get
into a really disparate situation
you'll do something experimental you'll
undergo a surgery because you see no
other choice and again that's where we
are going the language in this
particular bill just to bring it back to
this bill is been very well vetted by
multiple organizations dealing with
national uh and different States
including New Hampshire's arguments I
think it is extremely thorough and
thoughtful it removes politics from the
determining of the delegates it prevents
our contribution at least to a runaway
convention we can't control other states
and what other states delegates do and
it holds our delegates accountable
um whenever I think a committee has a
good idea before it in the form of
multiple bills as you do now I think
it's a good uh rule of thumb to pass one
and retain the other for study so that
you get a second bite at the Apple the
following year I would recommend that I
do prefer this language I understand it
is more complex than your other bill
um so I would ask that you pass this one
and retain the other one and make
amendments to the other one should this
one not pass the Senate however if you
feel more comfortable with the simpler
language I am I've already offered to
Wolf Pack to work on Amendment language
for either Bill and you could pass that
one and retain this one and study the
more complex one over the the fall
either way I do think that we really
need to act because it's kind of getting
scary out there and with that I will
take questions
represent Finney
thank you I appreciate you being here
um I have a question about some language
at the end of the bill I'm on page eight
lines 9 through 15.
um I just want a point of of some
clarification if you will
um it seems like lines nine through
fifteen one a a uh
they're
um it was a felony charge for violating
whatever oath you that you would take as
a delegate to this convention now is
this based specifically on RSA 641 1A
um because I don't I don't see the uh
the actual like um the class charge in
here and I I kind of have have like a
two-part question here
um
part the first in article 10 of our of
our state constitution allows us the
right to Revolution would you then agree
that any person that would make some
sort of
like Insurrection type statement or a
vote
um would be considered treasonous
which doesn't seem to be the case here
so I'm just trying to guess
clarification on on what it is the
felony specifically charging if if the
delegate um was to go back on whatever
that they're charged to do with this
convention sure so first of all a
delegate that in this case would run to
be a delegate or offered to be appointed
as a delegate is agreeing to a certain
set of rules so it's they they're
already agreeing to that the felony so
um and I'm going to put on my criminal
justice hat for a second we have four
mental States of uh criminal culpability
in New Hampshire it's uh negligent
Reckless knowing and purposeful so that
depends on how much thought and you know
intent you've given to that crime
knowingly is the next to highest state
so a person would have to have not
recklessly not negligently but knew that
they were going against what they were
told to do and did it anyway knowing
that it would would be unethical
problematic what have you the right to
Revolution as I understand it in our New
Hampshire Constitution is specific to
New Hampshire so kind of different from
our delegation to a convention
other questions
gagne
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh getting back to
the
what the
prior representative said uh
a person is guilty of a felony okay here
two classes of felony which one are we
talking about here one is an A and A B
and your penalty is is significant my
understanding and I am not a lawyer full
disclosure but having written a
significant number of bills with OLS my
understanding is when it says felony
it's up to the prosecution whether to
charge it as an ARB
just a follow-up
follow up as you well know uh this is
like what you believe as you well know
Class B is three and a half to seven the
class A is seven and a half to Fifteen
there's quite a difference there for
just deciding to not you know I'm not
going to go along with the dictates of
what the convention we give thank you
for the question we give prosecution
latitude in a lot of cases depending on
the evidence and the clear intent of the
person committing a crime I'm speaking
very broadly on all criminal cases
um but so would there be a reason to
have a difference between say somebody
who felt like got into the process was
at a convention and then felt a strong
uh moral internal obligation to go
against what they had promised and what
they had sworn to versus someone who
knowingly and purposefully went into
a sec declaring their oath saying that
they're going to hold to it but
purposely was trying to for example
overthrow the entire government
I think that is fair for prosecution to
make that claim however however I'm
already have offered to work on a number
of amendments with wolf pack on either
this bill or the other Bill and happy to
clarify that make a difference for
example between knowingly for class B
and purposefully for class A
purposefully as you know is or maybe you
don't know you're not in criminal
justice but you probably know requires a
very very very high threshold of proving
actual intent premeditated that's what I
would ask for
right
for the questions
thank you Russian Reed thank you Mr
chair and is there anyone else who wants
your needs to speak on this measure and
seeing none at this time as you were
yes if you can be very succinct and give
us some clarification
um from wolf pack that uh that would be
appreciated I just wanted to point out
that as representative Reed said
um it would only be for those who
knowingly violate their oath and as
representative Reed said somebody may
feel that they have a moral duty not to
follow the oath resignation is always an
option in that case and that's what
happened or what was offered to happen
in in the case
um that I had mentioned two weeks ago
where representative said they could not
follow their oath in the in the article
7 convention and gave the the town of uh
boscoin the chance to replace them if
they so chose in this case similarly if
you feel like you have a moral duty you
cannot follow your oath you can resign
and then you would not uh run the risk
of of any sort of felony if you know
that you are violating if you know that
you cannot follow your oath and then you
still act then I would think that would
be a reasonable cause for criminal
prosecution
just a brief question and I realized
we're running late
Justin having a felony in the build have
some of a chilling effect on a delegate
wouldn't it made more sense to make it a
misdemeanor a Class B if you wanted
someone incarcerated for a year but made
it a misdemeanor offense instead of a
very severe felony offense I don't know
representative Newell's position on that
personally I would yeah I know
personally I would be fine with an
amendment to make it a misdemeanor if
that's preferred by this committee I
don't know if representative renewal
agrees with that
um I I do think that one issue that has
come up before is making sure that
penalties are sufficient as a deterring
deterring effect and that has been an
argument that has been raised against
some uh language the um the strongest
deterrence though is the is the
provision to remove and replace somebody
to invalidate their votes and replace
them with somebody else because of that
I don't think that as strong a felony
deterrent effect is necessary so I'd be
okay with either way thank you for
thank you for that I point out
representative Reed is still in the
house in terms of uh that possible
amending language uh that representative
shartliff alluded to and uh I do note
that you're saying the town of Boston uh
better every time you uh you you say
it's evolved native to New England from
the scouts yeah enough that I should be
able to from baskawan to Bosco and okay
thank you again thank you
and with that
I will call this uh calling into this
hearing
on HB 392 I'm going to recess for about
one minute just one minute and then
we'll jump right into uh HCR 7.
thank you
researcher and I asked her to do some
research on this uh this topic and this
issue and she's I've already seen her
initial uh work and she's passing this
out to the committee so we have a week
to process uh the research that she's
giving us and the testimony of which it
sounds like we'll have quite a lot of it
so we want to get smarter about this and
uh so right now we just want to listen
and we'll start with the prime sponsor
thank you representative
thank you chairman Moffett and thank you
honorable representatives and my
colleagues
um Kauai and the Lizzy Sally Gould and
wikiak massive
and in our Abenaki language I said hello
my name is Sherry Gould and I was born
in Peterborough and I live near Lake
massasicum in a little section of Warner
halfway between Bradford and haniker I'm
here as a representative of Merrimack
District 8. I was asked to run and I ran
in a very transparent manner
for this very opportunity to sit in this
seat
for a very long time there has been a
barricaded door to recognition of
Abenaki people in New Hampshire
my goal is to do everything in my power
to get us through that door together
as a legislature and as an abanaki
Community as a whole
so I am a Mohegan tribal member enrolled
in the nohegan tribe 10 years ago when
we did the commission on Native Affairs
Bill representative Carr made an attempt
to recognize all labunaki in New
Hampshire
OLS chose to do a word replace and
change the word Abenaki to Native
American all throughout the bill once
again erasing abernaki from anything in
the legislature positive for us uh
since that time Vermont recognized four
bands for those of us who have always
been New Hampshire people who are still
New Hampshire people who will die New
Hampshire people we were put in a
situation where it would be illegal for
us to continue to sell our baskets under
the Indian arts and crafts act or any
art and there were other
minor things affecting us if we were not
enrolled in a tribe as a genealogist I
am a professional genealogist I was
appointed as the first genealogist to
the commission on Native affairs
by the New Hampshire Society of
genealogists and I had offered to help
the nohegan ban with their genealogies
for their recognition process and became
clear that my family band was kin to the
nohegan family band and so it made sense
to enroll
affording me the protection that New
Hampshire denied me as a resident and an
Abenaki person living in New Hampshire
so I am not a Vermont Indian I've never
been a Vermont Indian I am enrolled in a
tribe that affords me the protection
under the federal law
this bill is now hegan's attempt and
um I'm presenting it as an elected
representative on behalf of nohegan to
show the state of New Hampshire that
there is a very simple path for State
recognition and to try to educate you
all about what that means
it does not uh when a tribe is applying
for recognition whether it's state
recognition or federal recognition each
tribe applies for themselves among the
Abenaki there is no overarching Abenaki
Nation we don't have a grand Council of
Abernathy we have individual bands and
there are many bands in New Hampshire
this bill does nothing to diminish any
other band it shows a path that makes it
possible for every band and this
committee has to decide what the
criteria is for recognition in New
Hampshire
so I'm going to briefly cover federally
recognized tribes that's done by the Bia
the Bureau of Indian Affairs I've handed
around
a sheet to you all that shows
the web address whoops the web address
and all the criteria for federal
recognition you'll see at the top of the
handout that I put in State Rec if you
search those regulations those criteria
there is nothing mentioned anywhere
about State recognition the federal
requirements for recognition do not
reference State recognition
I've also handed out to you
from the National Conference of State
legislatures a sheet on state
recognition that outlines what state
recognition means it states in there
that there are some benefits to the
tribe for State recognition they're very
limited and there are four departments
federally that can bestow
um Can appropriate money to state
recognized tribes or to states that
acknowledge their state recognized
tribes
so that's all outlined in this and I
know you all can read so I'm not going
to read it to you
the bottom line is that
State recognition oh I also distributed
to you earlier a law brief on
all of the state recognized tribes
Nationwide and how they achieve State
recognition so the state has the
authority to recognize tribes they can
do it through many different means one
of which is
a resolution a simple resolution the
states reserve the right to bestow
whatever privileges or responsibilities
on a state recognized tribe they choose
to do so a simple resolution that is
simply acknowledging the historic and
cultural contributions that have
tribe we use the word band but tri-band
it means the same thing
that bestows no rights and
responsibilities what it does do though
is it triggers these four federal
agencies to be able to release funds so
for example right now the Department of
Labor is sending all the job training
money for Native Americans to Vermont
because there's no entity in New
Hampshire New Hampshire's never
recognized anybody
so this simple resolution would free up
New Hampshire to be receiving that
Department of Labor money that's
currently going to Vermont
so
um I think that pretty much covers I'll
take any questions at the end on the
federal and state it gives a path to
recognition it defines rights and
responsibilities and you've gotten the
historical information
it's important to remember each tribe
applies directly so any band can say do
do you know we want a resolution to
recognize us it is not in any way the
intention of HCR 7 to diminish anyone
else in New Hampshire we are not
um looking to do anything to hurt
anybody else
there is a great deal of historical
trauma and it's not just on the Abenaki
people it's on the subtler people
our band stayed in New Hampshire always
the you know at contact Phillip stayed
in New Hampshire I've shared with you
the link to the 26-year committee that
studied the issue of Philip was he Chief
wasn't achieved did another band have
all the kind of weeds we can crawl in
that that historical trauma I didn't
mention I'm I have a master's degree in
social work my concentration was
Community psychology
so we see a great deal of trauma we see
a great deal of confusion fear on both
sides of this issue and what I'm telling
you is we really it really is much
simpler we always live together we
worked with our colleagues
Philip was friends with Thomas seems he
sold him the land today uh each band has
their colleagues that they work with
so uh I think we can get through this
barricaded door I think I believe we can
do this
a few more comments uh we do have
nelhegan does have a non-profit in New
Hampshire registered New Hampshire aha
you'll hear some testimony about that
I'm not going to go into a lot of it
um we have Abenaki Trails project we
started we've been doing a great deal of
work in the area from
um Hopkinton to Sunapee to the Monadnock
region so following the Kentucky River
and the Warner River with the Community
Partners
New Hampshire is one of only 12 St
States who have no state or federally
recognized tribe in the fact that I
handed out I listed the other states
you know it's New Hampshire has to
decide is this an illustrious list you
want to be a part of or is are you ready
to acknowledge that the Abenaki people
in the various bands remnants who
survived are the original people of New
Hampshire and and recognize that you
already have a path to recognize people
you can limit you have all the power and
authority we do I'm a representative too
to limit it's hard I have two hats here
I'm trying to keep them separate
um but we can do this we can do this
the language that were used in the
recognition is really no different than
the language that's already in RSA 12a
for the commission on Native Affairs
which I already told you a word replaced
took Abernathy out and put Native
American in but for recognition as I
told you each band needs to ask for the
recognition in their own name
um
so we can start to move ahead today
I've looked at the
portal with the comments I think when I
left home it was
something like 215 and supportive and 95
opposing there's various points of law
being expressed by concerned citizens
which I'm really glad people are
bringing those up and people are looking
at them I know this committee is going
to take a week to review all of this
I've provided some information to
representative shurt-lived regarding the
questions about threat or harm to other
tribes in Vermont which are are not the
Attorney General's office has provided
some information the chief can speak to
that and
um
and other than that and and some issues
around you know is nohegan is it it's
almost as if it's become a popularity
contest this isn't a vote about which
band you like this is about is New
Hampshire going to recognize our
original people and if we are are we
going to provide a path for every band
that can meet whatever criteria this
committee sets forth and I think that
sums it up I'll take some questions on
the history the genealogy any of those
kind of questions I probably can answer
those best but we'll have other experts
test on other areas so I may pass on
some
thank you representative gold questions
for the prime sponsor representative
Mesa Miller
I just want to thank you for clarifying
to the committee that this will open the
door for other uh bands to apply because
when I was when I was reading it I was
questioning and of course you've gotten
emails from people as well about other
bands being included so thank you very
much for doing that thank you
Frozen Sherlock if you have a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you
Representatives always good seeing you
um my question is a concern I have about
this bill being before this committee
um as representative Master Miller just
alluded to there'd be other bands could
come forward and seek recognition
through this Committee in the New
Hampshire house and hopefully the Senate
wouldn't it make
be better to put in a bill to set up the
same kind of a commission that they have
from Vermont uh the the Vets the bands
with Vermont has the nine points in
their criteria and to have the
department of cultural and historic
Affairs be that body to vet those
different bands as you just heard we
took up we heard a bill on a con Article
5 convention next is my issued Marxism
be stopped from becoming a state of
religion and I just wonder if this is
the right venue for this bill to be
heard
so it really depends on how much rights
and responsibilities the state wants to
bestow Vermont's process and again if
you I please please please if you are
sincere in your desire to learn and
understand which I believe you are read
that law review that I emailed you all
and if you need me to email it again
I'll be happy to do that because it
discusses this you know some states give
the tribes a lot of Rights and
responsibilities some do what this is
asking we acknowledge you have a
historic and cultural tie to the state
that it's proven in history and that you
you are here today
so and with that comes nothing we're not
asking for any money we're not asking
for anything else what we are asking for
is that department heads listen to us
right now when I call Fish and Game they
say New Hampshire doesn't recognize any
tribes and I say well I'm enrolled in
the nelhagen tribe which is recognized
by the state of Vermont and what the
state of Vermont has recognized you
cannot unrecognize that gets to that
that trigger under federal law that we
have a status so the federal law repres
recognizes three different statuses for
tribes federally recognized that's what
goes to casinos to land claims to all
those things State recognition gives
nothing for that
you also have been hearing in some of
your testimony that state recognition is
a step toward Federal recognition that
is not true and that's what I was in the
handouts I was saying is that if you
look at the code there's nothing in
there about State recognition if you
look at the state recognition there's
nothing in there about it leading too it
does say there are federally recognized
tribes that are also state recognized
those are just two equal facts they're
not steps that lead one to another then
I gave you testimony from a hearing in
2007 where Senator Dole specifically
asked the chairman groins
um
about State recognition and did it help
with their the Lumbee tribes Federal
recognition and he said you know we've
been state recognized for 120 years
Senator Dole thank you for asking but uh
the Bia the federal government throws
that aside they don't even look at that
that does nothing to help us with
Federal recognition so if you pass this
resolution you make it as simple as you
want you take as little write some
historic and cultural contributions you
pass resolutions all the time and what
I'm hearing from my colleagues is oh but
that's just fluff it means nothing what
it means is it flips that switch at the
federal level to allow us to receive
limited funds funding to the state to
the Native Americans in the state
and it allows us to call fishing game
and say you know these permits we have
because we're state recognized Abenaki
to carry feathers can we sit down and
talk about that so we don't have
misunderstandings in the field and it
allows Fish and Game to get the
understanding that that saying New
Hampshire doesn't recognize any Abenaki
so I don't see any harm in saying yes to
this and at the same time looking at how
do we provide a path for others and do
you want to give more rights and
responsibilities to Native Americans but
we have a path now and it's a path
available to every band
one follow-up Mr chair follow up thank
you
um my other concern is this is a house
concurrent resolution yes and under
Center rule 3-23 I think it is they do
not accept house resolutions per se
it goes through the process of uh being
a late filing it is a uh a two-thirds
vote of the Senate to take that bill
into the chamber to even discuss it and
I think that's an awful High burden to
have 16 Senators that will agree to even
hear this knowing our Senate thank you
representative shurtle if you mentioned
that to me yesterday and last night I
had the opportunity to talk to one of
the co-sponsors of the bill Senator
David Waters and um so this it does take
a two-thirds vote for any res resolution
concurrent resolution many of them go to
the Senate many of them are accepted uh
this committee has the work to do of
this committee and what the Senate
chooses to do is what they'll choose to
do that would be the next step so I
really don't think that that's a
consideration that needs to weigh on
this committee no I mentioned that only
as a courtesy to you well thank you the
hurdle that you've got to get over thank
you um I I worked very hard on House
Bill 6 1610 for the commission on Native
Affairs I was basically the secretary
for representative Carr and I learned
what the sausage making
analogy was all about his back was right
yeah yeah thank you very much thank you
representative Kerry
I'm I'm curious as to why only one band
was recognized and why not all bands of
Abernathy because of course I also being
a born in this state Granite stator am
aware there's more than just one band
that exists in the state and I guess
that was my first I'll be honest with
you reaction was why aren't all
Abernathy recognized
I think I've answered that but I'll try
to um clarify it again that um
in any form of recognition whether it's
Federal recognition or state recognition
each band applies like you don't bring
all the Abenaki into say the grand hall
and and dub them Abernathy it's not how
it works are all Native Americans so
each each band each tribe has their own
their own everything in their own
history their own membership roles their
own leadership and we're not bound
together by any Grand Council or
anything
so each tribe applies for themselves and
I would hope you would see a lot more
requests for
recognition but nowhegan can only ask
for recognition for themselves so it
would not you would never see in Vermont
when they set up that very complex
process and I know representative
shirtle as he indicated has gone through
that and so is David Waters and in that
law review you'll see that it's one of
the most complicated or comprehensive
processes in the country
each tribe applied in their own right by
themselves it was not a group
application and and there's also been
some talk about how other tribes in
Vermont would get punished by the
actions of nelhegan same thing holds
true there's no group punishment and in
fact uh Chief Stevens will probably talk
to that one concern that was raised but
we're all individual tribes each tribe
applies in their own name and both as a
member of the tribe and as the
representative asked to submit this on
behalf of the nohigan tribe that's what
I've done I would certainly submit a
bill for any other tribe that asked and
so could any of the other 399 reps
anything else represent Finney
thank you
um you spoke earlier about this bill
isn't asking for any funding but you but
you did say that if if you know excuse
me if we were to pass it it would
trigger
um Federal
um funding uh
mechanisms can you speak to how much
money went to Vermont or how much money
would come to New Hampshire if this was
to pass
I could not give those exact details I
Know Chief Stevens will be able to speak
to what that means in terms of
triggering the ability to apply for
funding I know that in Vermont they're
doing a lot of things I don't try to
become an expert in Vermont law or or
funding sources but I do know that as
outlined in the National Conference of
State legislatures thing on State uh
recognition those agencies are
um
are allowed under law under federal law
to allocate money and whether that money
is going to go into the state treasury
or not I think Chief Stevens will be
able to tell you more about that
anything else for the prime sponsor
okay representative thank you for your
introduction of this measure and
pointing out also that there is a portal
that uh folks have already been to Great
extent and effect uh submitting some
perspectives and information and I would
invite you uh we'll exec this in a week
so we have some time to process the
information that we're getting and I
want to thank uh Chris Dyer again for
her work
um getting us some background so but I
invite you to uh respond to the
committee I'm not sure how long you can
stay today but if you want to respond to
some points that are brought up later as
the prime sponsor I will I invite you to
do that okay and I can stay as late as
you want I
um how how and when would you want me to
do that chairman
okay it's a little bit open-ended and it
brings me to the other point I wanted to
make representative Belcher is in the
house correct yes so he is the sponsor
of uh HR 15. I want to just explain
something real quick in terms of our
scheduling
um our rules are sets that we can we
list the measures that we're going to
hear
and we cannot start early
so and I'm sure you understand this but
just so everybody else understands and I
want to alert representative Belcher
that I have nine pink cards here and I
we all very much look forward to hearing
the testimony of the folks who took the
time to come in especially today so
it'll be a while before you get to HR
15. I know you're in another committee
so it'll be at least uh 11 o'clock or
later just FYI
uh we so we can't start early we can run
late we'll run as late as we need to
because we appreciate and honor uh you
folks taking the time to come in here
um sometimes we'll schedule a hearing
and it'll be introduced in two two or
three minutes and there's no one else to
testify and then we have to sit here
um until for it varies for however long
until the next one can start so that's a
time management thing that we're doing
so just you understand that uh if you're
here for HR 15 or the subsequent
measures uh we'll get to them but they
won't happen
um as scheduled that said uh I thank you
again representative okay we have uh
some pro and con in opposing the bill
I'd like to invite uh Paul and Denise
pouliott
to uh and they are here they've been
here before
I
from Alton
from the Kawasaki band of the Penacook
abnaki people you can explain better
um
your Native American indigenous Heritage
and you and you're both welcome to sit
there
we
unfortunately the State House Portal had
a lot of glitches
and a lot of testimony was uh
reported back that it was uh that this
hearing the testimony was closed earlier
this week which meant that a lot of
people ended up
forwarding documents to us which we
are giving to you now
um this was an unfortunate situation
obviously
um
we
we have our own testimony
and a testimony of quite a few other
tribal leaders from the region that are
included in this I too went through the
I'll introduce myself in a minute but I
want to get this kind of the the
business side of this uh cleared up
I'm going to speak right into the mic we
just want everybody to have all the
documents ahead of time before we start
we'll do our introductions in a second
here thank you for taking the time to do
that I have the copy of the uh the hard
copies that you made up thank you for
taking the time to do that
you're welcome
we wanted to make sure everyone's voice
was included in this process
so we have that for our files thanks
again for doing that so uh Paul and
Denise uh yeah please uh
tell us uh we're going to introduce
myself who you are and where you're from
and and uh your perspective on this
quad needlebach and delos and Denise
pulio Saga with Delaware pulio sagamo
kawasakbanded Panic people
Hello friends my name is Denise puglio
I'm the head female speaker and this is
Paul puglio head male speaker in Chief
of the kawasak band of the patent cook
abnaki people we come to you today from
our ancient Penacook Village called
odanakunippi which translates to the
Village of narrowing Waters now called
Alton New Hampshire
we come to you today to oppose HCR I'm
sorry hcr7
as an extremely damaging Bill to the
indigenous community at Large
we agree a recognition process should be
established in the state however this is
not the way to do it
if you want to really recognize the
abnaki of the state as you know there
are multiple tribes and show a
recognition process should be
established not make resolutions to
establish tribes without any vetting of
what's stated within those resolutions
as a
as your tribe of record that is uh
petition the federal government for
acknowledgment we petition the federal
government in 1995
it's recorded in the Federal Register uh
of that time period
um
the federal standard to be accepted is
uh widely considered the gold standard
to to acknowledge and recognize tribes
it includes
massive amounts of comprehensive
historical documentation genealogical
evidence and continuing governance
documents
this is what it calls this is what a
genealogy looks like not just a random
thing from you know ancestry.com this is
comprehensive history of the Penacook
abnaki people in here in New Hampshire
this is vetted resources in fact this
document has got almost a hundred vetted
historical narratives in it
this is anthropological evidence
this book was meant to to distort and
call it distorted descent indigenous
claims
that French people were making in Canada
that they were abnaki indigenous people
chapter one in this
is about our tribe chapter one
it very clearly states that out of a 900
uh sample 900 member sample they deemed
it 40 percent and more were a descendant
from indigenous women
now that may sound like something but in
Canada they were saying that only you
could only be descended from Chiefs or
men
so that's why this narrative was created
the last chapter in here
describes the nohigans as a
as a Vermont legislatively created group
with no historical evidence whatsoever
our tribe has been working with the
Canadian abnaki for for decades and
decades I was elected chief of the
kawasak band of Pinnacle cabinet people
in the 1990s
I've listened to
representative Gould's testimony
this is just one of two that she's
proposed
these are very damaging in a lot of ways
we we say a resolution like this really
needs to be based on some kind of vetted
historical narrative
states that have done resolutions or
proclamations recognizing tribal groups
like the Virginia tribes they had
well-documented history of these groups
like the nip muck in Massachusetts they
had a small patch of land in North
Grafton in the state of Massachusetts
recognized that they had a deep and long
presence for you
as you read this bill
resolution
um
there's going to be things that are
going to relinquish the state
sovereignty over the right to recognize
a group
this complex process was put in place by
the federal government for a purpose it
wasn't an arbitrary thing it was to keep
this kind of thing from happening
this resolution fails to meet any of
those criteria
in 2011 the Vermont legislative process
that recognized the Mohegan ban
expressly stated
they could not be recognized in any of a
state Province or Nation
this is a very firm thing the federal
government has put into place on all the
recognition processes unless that tribe
had multi-state reservations like in the
southwest they said you had to have a
basis for where you came from
this law into this resolution
would actually invalidate that because
it says very clearly in the enabling
legislation from Vermont they cannot be
in any other state Province or Nation
furthermore the state of Vermont
uh
you know all these things that she said
about not getting any additional
benefits that doesn't really apply
all they're trying to do is expand their
territory and expand their influence in
our state to gain grants and other
things this is a very one-sided thing
this is not lift up all of the abnaki in
this region
they already have direct access
through their own state agencies for all
these things that they've listed in in
this particular resolution
they had two seats on a commission in
our state at one point and they resigned
in 2021.
representative Gould also submitted a
bill HB 390 the bill will currently
remove all appointed New Hampshire
commission members and replace them with
members who are completely controlled by
the Vermont tribal leaders
and we'll also remove all state
appointed seat by agencies that are
already on the commission and thereby
eliminating all oversight
while relinquishing the state's
sovereignty over the commission because
it's being controlled by Vermont tribes
Vermont also set up that they had to
have at least 50 or or more so I say 51
percent of the tribal members have to be
from specific regions of Vermont because
they did divide the state up into
quadrants
the Mohicans were given uh Caledonia
Essex and I think
Marlene Williams yeah counties and there
was a map that was created by the
commission of Native American Affairs to
keep the the group separated and they
would know where their territories were
well it seems like the Mohicans
basically threw out the two premises
that they had to have the membership in
the state that they had uh particular
territories that they had to live within
and and now the United States trying to
push this through while we say that
there's a real need to recognize
indigenous people in the state this is
not the vehicle for it and they're going
about this the wrong way
when they started this narrative which
was very troubling
I tried
um back in the 1990s dealt with the what
we call this Phillips lease issue we
actually
we had constitutional Scholars and
attorneys show up at a tribal council
meetings and said should we should we be
pursuing this 1796 land lease or Grant
at the same time the odnaught tribe
which is a federally recognized tribe in
Canada was also looking at it because
after the war of 1812 there was a big
contentious issue about the lake Memphis
Magog area and this also spilled over
into our state politics when the Indian
stream Republic was established like in
the 1830s time period and Ox state had
to squash that because it was people
trying to make another Republic that was
outside the federal standards this lease
was looked at by Scholars and nobody and
I mean nobody can prove who this
Phillips was because at that time the
Canadian tribes which were the only
governance in place had no Chief named
Phillips
they were trying to find this as well
because they felt they could make a land
claim that would have included Lake men
for Magog
it was proven by them they couldn't do
it and we couldn't do it but the
overriding question is
people ignore the fact that George
Washington put in place in 1790 the
non-intercourse ACT
which because it was called the
Intercourse sect it prohibited this kind
of activity so this is what I call
historical myth of leases this has no
bearings being put into a into a
document that's going to be part of our
state history if it gets approved this
is an outright fabrication okay I'm
gonna just jump in here real quick we've
got a lot of uh material that's been
passed out for us to process in addition
to everything that's on the portal and
we also have at least eight or nine
other folks who want to testify so as
you wrap this up I I just want to ask
you to try to speak directly to the
resolution I love the history and we
need to focus on the this resolution and
why which you've done a good job I think
of explaining where you where your stand
on this but if if you could wrap this up
so we can stop move forward all right
the the resolution would make you think
that they're not going after anything
but in Vermont they after they got
enabled they filed over 90 pieces of
special interest legislation they have
now gained exempt property for tribal
land free hunting and fishing licenses
and a whole bunch of things which have
physical responsibilities that this
state may also look at
they also got uh
a a federal earmark for 350 000 from
Bernie Sanders Senator sandis to create
a position that was going to develop
their abnaki culture tribes that have a
culture don't need to have somebody
develop it for them
uh furthermore
you know we've been here for decades
working with this legislature we've been
presenting ourself as the regional
people
uh we've been lecturing at your churches
the historical societies your schools
and your town events
we really request that you look at this
really hard and fast because this is
going to relinquish a lot of State
sovereignty it's a slippery slope as
we'd say please itl this
quick recap
Vermont already gives their people the
right to sell indigenous arts and crafts
New Hampshire recognition for that tribe
would not change that they can already
do it so um to put that as a necessary
need for State recognition is just
conjecture the
New Hampshire Commission on Native
American Affairs has already established
where they did hold two seats on the
commission they resigned those two seats
in 2021
um the commission gives them direct
access to State agencies and speaking as
a head female speaker of a tribe we
already have a relationship with state
and federal agencies and we don't have
state recognition so it is possible to
maintain those relationships without
State recognition
I also want to say that it's been it's
been discussed whether or not Sherry
Gould is abusing her position and
committing an Ethics violation as the
New Hampshire house representative to
put forth two pieces of legislation that
directly benefit her her family and her
tribe in Vermont this issue should be
formally reviewed by the New Hampshire
Ethics Committee
and I want to thank you okay an Ethics
uh issue is a little is someone I know
you're tying this into the resolution
but we need to be careful about what
we're saying here in terms of an Ethics
violation vis-a-vis the the substance of
the resolution so I I caution you about
that uh but uh please go ahead and
finish up
no I'm pretty much done
um at the end of the day this process
does not help all the Abenaki within the
state if you really want to help the
abnaki in the state you would establish
an actual recognition process and not go
one by one and cherry picking who you're
going to recognize and I we don't think
the resolution of this type is really
the right venue for doing this uh this
historical narrative and trying to make
it into our state record it is the
inappropriate right vetting is important
vetting this is very important okay
Denise referenced the commission uh what
just what commission did you refer to
the commission on Native American
Affairs the New Hampshire Commission on
Native American Affairs
thank you other questions uh
representative massamila question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my questions
um so am I correct in understanding that
one of the reasons that you are opposed
to this bill is because you feel there's
not enough research regarding the Neil
Keegan ban correct
um we feel that the um the resolution
within its entire should be vetted and
well documented
um there are a lot of claims that we as
a tribal organization who's been you
know on the federal you know application
list since the early 90s
um there are things that they've made
claims to that we just actually can't
even prove and so if this is as a
resolution this will become a fact of a
basis of fact for the courts and so the
courts actually refer back to a lot of
these resolutions when they decide law
and so if we pass a resolution in the
state with questionable history and
what's that going to do in the long term
so as a tribe we fight very strongly for
truth in history and this is another one
of those situations
follow up
um do you feel that this is sort of a
land grab proposal when you start a
resolution out with a potentially
fictious land grant
um you know why would you put that in
there if you weren't after
um some sort of uh land grab then you
wouldn't have put that in there at all
it would have been strictly about
recognizing your people as an active
tribal entity within this state instead
they started off with a um with a land
statement it's it's damaging in a lot of
respects because uh we it's never been
proven this whole thing so putting it in
is a state document that's going to be
recorded and for posterity that's
already been disproven right and I just
want the committee to keep aware that if
they pass this resolution it actually
violates the Vermont recognition process
by acknowled being acknowledged in
another state if Vermont revokes their
recognition and state because of this
resolution is New Hampshire ready to
pick up that fiscal burden
we should also point out the Norwegian
tribe was created by legislation this
book covers New Hampshire
actually New Hampshire Penacook in
abnaki history there is not one not one
reference to nohegan ever ever in any
historic narrative and this goes back
with hundreds of cited you know cited
references there has never been one this
was a fabrication okay thank you are
there other questions or comments or not
comments or like looking for questions
uh one more no yes
represent Finney go ahead
um just uh one point of clarification
again please if you can
um there was a grant from Senator
Sanders in Vermont for the 350 000 if if
that state sovereignty was to be taken
away in Vermont uh you know we'd have to
uh to shoulder the burden of you know
the recognition of the tribe so then
would we then be made to uh be be
fiscally responsible for that money that
that had had already been granted plus
plus whatever else would be granted to
the tribe I wouldn't know you would have
to talk to Bernie Sanders about that we
don't we're not really sure how that was
done it was a 350 000 year mark it was
slated for some position in Vermont for
doing cultural development and was it a
federal bill it was a federal okay thank
you yeah it was to develop a culture
okay seeing no other further questions
okay I want to thank you for your
testimony and for the material that you
organized I know that took quite a lot
of time so thank you for the time okay
in support of the bill I have a card
here from Chief Dan Stevens
Chief Stevens is here welcome to state
federal and veterans
Chief Stevens
you have you have five or ten minutes
so uh again as I've said before if you
can avoid repeating anything that's
already been said that will help us to
move right along okay thank you
absolutely thank you Mr chair and uh
committee uh first I'd like to thank you
as a disabled vet what you guys do for
veterans because uh that's important I
just want to at least say that because
this is the committee that works for
veterans so I just wanted to at least
acknowledge that
um I was going to come up here and do uh
do a Spiel but I think I want to leave
more time to
um answer questions now I am Don Stevens
chief of the nohegan band of the kusak
one of the largest Abenaki tribes
codified in law in the United States so
I'm not gonna here to disparage anybody
I'm here to uplift and I'm only going to
say the difference between us and others
who may testify is that we are actually
legally codified in law as an Abenaki
tribe so we don't need vetting
uh we don't need a process for someone
to tell us who we are we have already
gone through that processes as you know
passing a bill in statute going through
the house and committees and the floor
and then the Senate and then being
reviewed by the attorney general and
then being signed by the governor if we
haven't been vetted by now I don't know
who uh who is because you understand
that process so I won't go through that
in our recognition Bill we are tied to
the Phillips land grant which I think
Miss uh Gould has provided that that was
actually
um
um filed in New Hampshire and part of
the Phillips tribe and it goes across
the upper part of New Hampshire over
that Grant goes over to
umbagog so I'm not going to even get
into the legalities of what's a real
Grant or what isn't I mean that is in
New Hampshire law already and that has
already been
um
uh vetted so I'm not even going to get
into all that stuff so the reason why am
I here
uh
I am the leader of our tribe who needs
to represent our people no matter where
they live and we have 400 citizens or
Plus in the state of New Hampshire so it
is my role in my job is to support the
citizens who live here and the families
traditionally and currently living in
the state of New Hampshire we are not
here to disparage anybody we are not
here to step on anybody to lift
ourselves up just like in the state of
Vermont I have been involved in the
political world and working I actually
helped with the recognition process I
was chair of the Vermont Commission on
Native American Affairs before we got
recognition appointed by Governor Jim
Douglas in 2006 so I'm pretty familiar
with the process and I also was Chief at
the time that we went through the
recognition process so any questions you
have around that is fine
um and we uh no no he even got
recognized in two thousand 11 along with
El Nu and then masiscoe were recognized
in 2012 along with the kawasak tribe as
miss school stated that each tribe
represents herself as a sovereign tribe
with their own leaders and in our own
history so the difference of why we're
asking you to to acknowledge us a we
have been vetted a we are we have a
historical and continued presence in the
state of New Hampshire and we would we
want a seat at the table so whether you
recognize us outright or you acknowledge
the fact that we are codified in law as
an Abenaki tribe and protected under the
federal Indian arts and crafts act that
um we have a seat at the table because
currently we do not and when it comes to
funds I was involved with writing the
Congressional Grant with Bernie Sanders
so I'm the one who administers it so if
you have a question on the Congressional
Grant I'd be willing to answer that
question
uh and also uh when it comes to funds uh
the differences are this say you have a
USDA Grant and they give a pool of money
for food to say they they Dole that out
based on state not by tribes so like if
I have a I have a grant through Vermont
to feed our people but it's only
restricted to Vermont I can't use those
funds in New Hampshire because that's a
different pool of money
because the USDA gives a pool of money
to New Hampshire to dull out it's so
even though we don't recognize European
borders the federal government and the
states do so these things we have a food
shelf in uh Kentucky that helps feed our
people down here so we have to get other
donations
um outside of those federal grants to
actually get money or food to like USDA
Commodities or other things to feed our
people so my role is to not to take over
New Hampshire it's just to be a player
and to be able to help our people as
much as I can because they're my
constituents and they're my they're my
citizens and that's what my job is and
what I do do not affect
um you know the Penacook or or the
pulios if they decide that they want to
go for recognition and have a
relationship with you that's their
business that's their choice I don't
care what they do I care what we do I
care what noelhegan does and I am asking
for a relationship with the state of New
Hampshire and or order so I may
represent our people and our people are
being able to be um
to be uh included as an indigenous
people in New Hampshire and yes did we
have people on the commission yes but
the commission became toxic so both of
our citizens resigned from the
commission because we weren't being
represented and they decided they had to
step off for their own health and
well-being because that's why one of the
bills are coming up to deal with a
commission because we had somebody apply
to get back on the commission and that
was denied
so I'm saying is so we we couldn't go
that Avenue for representation so I will
stop there and let you ask questions of
me
um because I'm very familiar with the
recognition process what it does and
doesn't do and also with any grants that
may come or not be
come so I I've been around for a while
so thank you Mr chair thank you
questions uh Russell Finney
thank you for acknowledging that so I'm
asking for us in New Hampshire would you
then be applying for a grant in New
Hampshire in the same way that you got
one in Vermont
um not necessarily the earmark that I
got I work with a lot of legislative
delegations Patrick Leahy is Bernie
Sanders of course Pat Lee he's left now
um we applied for a grant for cultural
purposes now do we know our history yeah
but it's all over the place so we have
to gather that up so it's a resource for
education for children as a as a
resource for many you know Scholars
other people who want to look at
different parts of History this
Congressional Grant was given so we
could gather those things so we could
have someone do that so it doesn't
matter if they live in New Hampshire or
Vermont or whatever it's for the
norwegan tribe in order to do what they
need to capture their their culture and
gather it from various resources like we
said there are many tribes throughout um
throughout historically through out New
Hampshire mass and Maine and and trying
to gather all those informations and
working with other people to get the
information that's the goal of it it's
it's we know our culture but we have to
gather it for resources and that's what
this Congressional Grant is and it's
backed up by the National Archives so
um this is not an easy feat to do so
could we apply we'd have to go through
the New Hampshire congressionals they'd
have to decide but that isn't our our
goal right our goal isn't to all of a
sudden try to take over the world our
goal is to help our people and if it
helps the people and uplift the citizens
of New Hampshire at the same time what's
why is that bad right I mean why is that
bad if we uplift people and we have a
specific relationship to you and it
doesn't it's up to the other people to
decide what relationship they might have
with you you don't have to tear somebody
down to lift somebody else up right I
mean there's room enough for everybody
here okay other questions uh for the
chief uh Prime sponsor just
yes I'm gonna allow that because I
specifically invited you to do so
briefly thank you I just want to clarify
what happened was Bernie Sanders got a
line item in the federal budget
appropriating 350 000 to the department
the National Archives uh the national
naira Don then had to fill out the
paperwork to State how that money was
going to be spent to gather cultural
materials so he's gathered he can't buy
physical items this is all about
photographing 3D scanners going around
to museums it's not paying for any
positions it doesn't pay for salaries it
would not create any financial burden if
it goes away
um it doesn't create any financial
burden for New Hampshire and could you
explain the going away from Vermont well
I just that question needs to come from
the committee does anybody want to ask
that question
okay we we need to move along if there
are no other questions Chief thank you
uh did I say end up
uh representing I I am curious about
this so they were okay earlier okay
thank you Mr chair okay
and you're welcome to answer just
understand that any a lot of these
grants Congressional grants are
reimbursement models you have to spend
the money and then get reimbursed so
even if something happened there would
be no more reimbursement because you
wouldn't be spending any money so I just
want to be clear that they don't just
hand you Congress doesn't just hand you
350 000 and say have fun you have to
spend the money you request it to be
reimbursed by the by the uh sponsor of
the Congressional Grant and then they
with receipts and then they reimburse
you so I just want to be clear that
um this is to document our our history
and our culture and there is no position
to actually do that I I use my salary in
kind to put towards gathering this
information and having other people do
the work so it's not a position like in
the tribe it's just part of the well you
know how Congressional earmarks work I
mean so well thank you for that
clarification other questions
not seeing any Chief thank you for your
time I'm looking for uh Nancy I'm going
to try to read this Nancy Marcio
from New London you ever need me just
you know where to find me please thank
you
Nancy is in opposition to the bill and
Nancy if you could for the record uh
pronounce your name uh better than I
probably just did
uh Nancy maracio I represent the League
of Women Voters
it was close thank you Nancy
it's Italian
um I'm going to mostly read this because
I represent the league
New Hampshire is the only New England
state that does not recognize its Native
American tribes the League of Women
Voters supports the need for recognition
of New Hampshire tribes but not through
Vermont tribes
before the nohegan ban was recognized in
Vermont the Vermont Commission on Native
American Affairs was required to submit
a recommendation that the general
assembly of Vermont
recognized or not recognize
or to deny recognition to the applicant
more than 30 States including New
Hampshire have liked commissions New
Hampshire's commission charge includes
furthering the needs of New Hampshire's
Native American community Through State
policy and programs
New Hampshire's commission was not
involved in this
resolution and should have been
the League of Women Voters New Hampshire
supports New Hampshire tribal
authorities not Vermont for decisions
about New Hampshire tribes
opposes tribal bans recognized in
Vermont as a voice in New Hampshire
tribal decisions and supports the New
Hampshire Commission on Native American
Affairs as the trail toward criteria
recognition of all New Hampshire tribes
the league urges unanimous rejection of
HCR 7.
thank you for that statement
from the League of Women Voters
questions
not seeing any thank you again for
taking the time and for giving us that
statement and now we go to
Sherry and I'll ask Sherry for the wreck
if she's here uh to help us for the
record with the correct pronunciation of
the of the last name from Louden
Sherry Perna
and uh Sherry is in opposition to the
Bill thank you
thank you very much for uh hearing my
humble opinion
um but strong
I I
am a New Hampshire resident for years
and a member of the co-as traditional
band of sovereign Abenaki nation of
Alstead I'm a member of the church Jesus
Christ of Latter-day Saints I'm a member
of the New Hampshire committee for
Native American Affairs and I'm a
registered voter
I'm right I'm
reading this as a private citizen
because I have several concerns with the
resolution
hdr7 as presented I'm its attempt to
recognize the Mohegan Abenaki band of
Vermont tribe
a Vermont tribe even though they reside
outside the state borders it should be
noted that none of the four Abenaki
tribes who reside within the state
borders are recognized by our state
government frankly this is a proverbial
slap in the face
for Abenaki natives who reside work and
vote in this state
the nahogan Abenaki who live in New
Hampshire currently have resources in
place
to see their needs the House of
Representatives the state senate the New
Hampshire Commission of Native American
fairs all deal with these issues
my great-grandparents immigrated from
Canada to New England in an attempt to
come back to their Homeland
unfortunately had they had to hide their
identity and their children's for safety
reasons
we are thankful that is now safe to
acknowledge Our Heritage the Abu dhaki
tribes should seek formal recognition by
the state of New Hampshire being
recognized would be both healing and
celebrated as I see it the state must do
for our own people first before
considering others
the state needs to formally establish
requirements for the tribe within our
state borders to be formally recognized
one such requirement must be that the
tribe resides in the state of New
Hampshire
recognizing the recognition of the
Vermont nohican event
will do nothing to advance our local
Native American culture within the state
nor the Abenaki nation's request for
formal recognition in the state the rod
abernakis are already supported by the
state of Vermont they do not need
additional support from the state of New
Hampshire
abernaki's Nation
the Abenaki nation in our fourth and of
War tribes within our state need full
support of the State of New Hampshire
the state supports
support of our own four tribes
will be beneficial to many including
tourism Artisans local industry as we
are intricate part of the state we are
already here and we are willing to stand
up to be officially recognized
now there are several points that came
up that bother me one is the land grant
and the legal ramifications of that that
is extremely disturbing
um you know if it sets a precedent for
our people or for the government because
even though my father's people are
Abenaki my mother's people were pilgrims
um vetting for ourselves we cannot rely
on another state to vet
our people
it is it's too important and it's it's
establishment of integrity
of the state to to uh have a vetting
process of ours of Our Own
and finally
we really do need to have a a system in
place for recognition because we are not
dealing with senators or politicians
we're dealing with men who were
archivists or Farmers or
you know School teachers
managers they're not going to understand
this they're going to look at this
ratification and be insulted they're
going to think that
our priorities are not with New
Hampshire and that is something you
really need to think about as your
constituents what are they going to
think
what are they feeling because they are
the people that you work for
I think that setting up a committee or
you know
a commission whatever we call that
um would be beneficial for everybody
because then the mo the the Vermont
tribe wants recognition here they would
have to follow the same steps as
everybody else
and be vetted just like everybody else
it would be a sign of cohesion and of
of order
that is needed in this process
okay because it's just this way it just
seems very backhanded and and it's not
it's not nice
it's just not a nice way to go about it
I thank you and uh
for listening
thank you share questions for this uh
representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
testifying uh you know this committee
has three options we can vote it up uh
we can vote it down but we have a third
option to retain the bill
would you support the idea of this
committee retain the bill in using that
as a basis for setting up a commission
using the Vermont uh indigenous peoples
commission to be the boilerplate for
what we would do here as an improvement
in what we have now I would support it
but I would not
um blindly state to use the Vermont
boilerplate system
um that is not
you know I question everything sure and
um yeah I would support that I would
like to be on it to be honest with you
but it has to be uniform and it has to
be the same for everyone you know
um we cannot rely on another State's
policies and I use the term boilerplate
and it's loose's Farm okay this is a
guide not to to take it per se yeah but
thank you thank you thank you very much
other questions
saying none thank you so much for your
your testimony uh next up I have uh in
opposition to the bill fun
um
find good death that's what I thought it
said from Romney I'm not going to ask
you this question while you're taking
your seat except I did I am wondering
how the indigenous folks
um stayed warm when it was 50 degrees
below
without electricity but that's that's a
rhetorical question thank you for being
here in opposition or in uh I'm sorry in
opposition to the Bill thank you so much
A lot of my points I was going to make
have been shared and I want to thank you
respect to state representatives for
your service on this committee and thank
you honorable veterans who served I want
to give a little background about who I
am my mother and father served in the
military my father is a Vietnam veteran
and the current commander of the VFW in
Plymouth Post 4483 and commander of the
American Legion imposed 66 Plymouth New
Hampshire and is on the board of
directors of Camp resilience in Guilford
New Hampshire I am also a proud
descendant of the blackfeet nation that
is a federally recognized tribe and a
New Hampshire resident my mother served
in the Army and was an enrolled member
of the blackfeet tribe my father is
indigenous blood as well I honor all of
you in them with great pride with my
strong background I am sharing my
opposition to hcr7 I'm concerned that
this resolution of racist the kawasak
ban to the Penacook Abenaki there is
archaeological evidence for 12 800 years
in documented historical evidence since
the 1500s of them in this Terry of New
Hampshire parts of Maine Vermont and
even up to Canada they are the true
stewards of this land and in addition
there is no process in this state to get
recognition and I would suggest that we
make a formal process of recognition and
using New Hampshire formal process
New Hampshire is a strong State we're
capable of making a formal process
a key Point here is a resolution is not
a law
some of the language in this resolution
is applied to federally recognized law
not a state recognized tribe now
federally recognized is different than
state recognized tribes someone can say
that their state recognized but it does
not have and I'm not saying what this is
right or wrong it's just the way it is
it's not the same as Federal recognition
so and then I listed other points and I
want to say that so as a descendant
and even if you were a member of a tribe
My Tribe the the tribe I'm a Descent of
is in Montana now there are still things
I have planned with my family in Montana
because people have passed away
unfortunately now I still get
information from them I'm not losing my
whatever I have with that with the tribe
while being out here they simply send me
the information my rights are not lost
I also would not come here and say that
I you know would like to you know
buy tribes in Montana
my the my family is in Montana I
understand that this is a hard issue
it's an emotional issue and I understand
that but there is a process is strict
and it's it's rigorous to attain Federal
recognition and even State recognition
there's a federal there's there's a
there's a process at the state level
and so but that has to be vetted that
should be vetted we can I simply think
that we should honor the genealogical
history but that has to be vetted
someone who has to follow a strict
process with that for federal
recognition for example you have to send
your birth certificate in you have to
have even your parents for certificates
and if you can go on and on and it's
looked back for generations and
generations you have to prove who you
are I think in this state I think we
have to come up with a formal process to
make this happen now
I want to say I've sent you my emails I
want to say something that's really
important the recognition of the four
Vermont tribal communities per
specifically prohibited the recognition
they were recognized as a tribal group
in any
other state Province or Nation putting
forward a recognition bill or resolution
such as this one is a direct violation
of the Vermont recognition process and
is strictly prohibited so in that sense
that would probably hurt the the league
and try and so I think moving forward
here they're saying that they're they're
not trying to take away anything from
the bands in New Hampshire but I feel
like it's saying two different things
the pro we have to honor and respect the
peoples that were here and in the
territory as large
Vince furthermore I know that we've
already heard that the about the
commission and the seats and all that
but I want to say the state of
convention already has a New Hampshire
Commission on Native American Affairs
therefore I don't feel that we need to
refer to the state of Vermont
for how to follow through with this
process
and it is open to all indigenous
residents of an all tribal affiliations
that give acts direct access to numerous
state agencies I want to say the kawasak
band of the Pinnacle copenhacki has a
working relationship at the state level
of many different issues and has even
worked at the federal level
the Mohegan held two seats on this
commission until the records
resignations in 2021 the Mohican band
members of the current New Hampshire
also submitted a bill Sherry gold state
represents the middle Bill HP 390 to
remove all current members of the
current New Hampshire native commission
and replace them with members who are
completely
controlled by the Vermont tribal leaders
I don't feel that that is just
if they're saying that they're not
trying to
um push out the kawasak ban to the
pentecoke panda Abernathy or other bands
in this state than I I don't understand
why that would happen and that's another
bill that's being put forth and I oppose
that
um
the hips and it removes and you have to
stay assigned numbers and it's the
oversight of New Hampshire and it I I
don't agree with that
and state recognition absolutely does
help Federal recognition if you look up
the Bureau of Indian Affairs which this
is where it follows it has a strict
process and one of the steps that helps
it and you can read it you can look it
up now if you like estate recognition
State recognition can be a part of that
in proving that you have a relationship
with the state
so
um so I think that I I would look
forward to
this bill being itl'd I think it would
be beneficial for the state to work from
a state recognition process and people
have to be vetted to say who they are
and
and I am open to taking any other
questions I want to say I also have
experience I grew up in New Hampshire I
lived on a reservation not mine because
there wasn't a dormitory there so I went
and lived on the Navajo reservation and
I went there for a few years and I have
that experience of not only having land
with my family and experiencing that my
families on many different
states and reservations we've spread out
we've inter mixed with other people but
having lived on the reservation too I
can speak to many issues with that
and if you have any questions please ask
me and I also gave you my phone number
and I know this is a hard and I have
compassion for people and I know this is
hard I know wanting to
get recognition is hard but I want to
also honor the process I want it to be
vetted and I want it to be truthful and
fair
thank you for that questions for for fun
representative shortlist
just a quick comment as a fellow Vietnam
veteran tell your dad welcome home thank
you so much thank you so much
thank you yes and I was going to say to
say thank you to both your parents for
their service and thank you for taking
your time here today come down from from
Romney
um
say no further questions and we'll go to
the next name on the card list we have
about four more
um
Sarah Smith is in favor of the bill
supports the bill sharers from Pembroke
I have a few copies of things
good morning
um members of the committee thank you
for um taking my testimony uh my name is
Sarah Smith I live in uh in Pembroke New
Hampshire also known as Suncook
um which was the name of the tribe that
originally lived there
so um
I I come here as um
as a member of the public but I'm also
uh affiliated with the Quakers in New
England and
um
uh I'm part of a group that helped put
out an apology to all the Native
Americans throughout New England
um and this was a process that we went
through for about two years uh because
uh we wanted to do it right
um so one of the things that we did was
look for all the tribes in New England
um and made it made ourselves our own
little database looking looking at
including at the the data that the um
uh State of New Hampshire provided
so because we wanted to make sure that
we we spoke to everyone
one of our basic principles is treating
everyone equally
and so I I come here with sort of a
moral argument are we are we treating
everyone equally here
um uh we in our process we made sure
that
when we sent out the letter of apology
uh you know we spent a year making sure
we were going to do it to the right
people and then made sure that we sent
it out at the same time so that
everybody would get it no one would be
treated differently
um and so I I urge you to follow that
principle of treating everybody equally
in this in this group the the
list that I have here are the people
that we identified as Abenaki and
in in Vermont and New Hampshire that we
could find
um actual groups of people represented
um and
uh so that's so those are the those are
the names that we used and we we sent
the apology to those people
um I and I would urge you to
to again
listen to all of those voices one of the
things that I've learned is that
uh in studying this is that
the voices of the Native Americans are
key in understanding what needs to be
done and that when the Europeans have
imposed settlements without those voices
being heard that that uh the
consequences have not been good
so
um in this situation we really need to
sit down with all of those voices
together and come to Unity
that's another principle that Quakers
use and I I believe it's a Native
American principle too to come to Unity
before you act
um and I don't sense Unity here
I don't sense Unity within this and
within the different functions here and
there needs to be there needs to be more
discussion before we act if we want to
come out with the right result
um I I can just I could point you over
to Maine too we haven't talked about
Maine Maine is having a terrible Pride
right now because they came to a
settlement that wasn't fair
and it has unintended consequences 40
years later and they're trying to undo
it
um and
so this I just point that out to you
because
we might be looking at this moment but
we have to think
um farther ahead the Native Americans
refer to this as
um Seven Generations ahead
what what is what will be the
consequences if we act on this
particular bill right now
I put myself in in support of it because
I want to support the the voices that
have raised it but I my support is based
on everybody being treated fairly and
equally here
um and so it's I it didn't have a place
to check that off and say but really are
you being fair to everyone so I would
urge you to really look at this
um uh and I think I'm not sensing that
kind of unity right now
um so
uh it's sort of like well I like this
idea but
I support it because I like the idea of
the recognition but I I feel like it's
not really there yet it's really not at
that process yet
so
um thank you for taking my testimony
thank you for your time and your
testimony coming here from Pembroke uh
questions
representative massamila
thank you Mr chair
um
when you sent out these letters you said
they were to recognize groups of
um Native Americans is that true and I
noticed that the null Higgins are here
so how were they recognized I mean did
you do research as far as the legitimacy
um yeah it's also so yeah it's a we try
to include people that really
not just that they had to have a
recognition but that they
self-identified in a strong way because
we don't feel that necessarily
um
the that European recognition defines
somebody
that their recognition is also important
so so that the groups that Define
themselves within New Hampshire were
recognized too
thank you
other questions
thank you again for your your testimony
and your time I have a card here from um
minimum Baker from Hillsboro uh but it
just says that she wants two minutes to
speak to HR blank so uh I'm guessing
that you want to speak to hr7
to this one yeah did I put the wrong
number uh there was no number so I just
want to make sure that you weren't here
to speak to uh 15 or 16 or and there is
an hr7 this this is HC our session uh
seven house concurrent resolution in
this thank you eventually we'll get to
HR 7. I'm not well versed on all the
we're still trying to figure it out here
too
yeah I'm Marion Baker Baker from
Hillsborough
and
when I looked in the room I realized
we're we're we recognize our mountains
we recognize our Rivers all of which
most of which have
Abenaki names and for a long time
increasingly I've been feeling
embarrassed that we're not recognizing
that there are Native Americans I'm not
sure the best way of doing it but we
need to recognize the Native Americans
amongst us of all that they have done
for us and are continuing to do for us
um
and so I'm
I'm a Quaker as well and wanting to lift
up I really want to thank the the pulos
and all the work they have done through
University of New Hampshire in educating
us about a lot of the history and what's
going on among Native Americans and I
want to thank Sherry Gould and Daryl
Peasley and others from the from the
Mohegan tribe that have also done a lot
of education for a lot of us that who
always were told there were no Indians
in the state they all died off
because of smallpox or went West
which has been proven is no no longer
true and by archaeological evidence
um
so I just hope that we can find a way
where we can recognize the
abenakis our neighbors
within our state
and I'm I'm voting in for the for the
bill because I would like to get the
process started at least recognize One
Tribe hoping other tribes will follow as
well until all tribes are recognized
so I just want to encourage us to find
some way to recognize
our our neighbors
thank you
will you take any questions if there are
any sure
are there any questions for this speaker
in singing and thank you
for taking the time to be with us today
I have three more cards
um
Catherine corkery is asked for two
minutes
um
Melinda Sim that's in opposition Melinda
Sims has asked for three minutes in
opposition and Carlos
Carlos Cardona who's been here before is
in opposition he doesn't have a time of
requested minutes so those are the three
that we have left is Catherine here
Catherine welcome
thank you thank you um and I'll be quick
I promise
um
welcome back
it's really great to see you all and I'm
honored to speak to this committee my
name is Catherine corkery I represent
New Hampshire Sierra Club and
um there are about 17
000 of our members and supporters in the
state
I
um New Hampshire Sierra Club asks for
caution as you approach HCR 7.
and
um Wrecking and we see that there are
some unintended consequences
uh that actually Force us to oppose the
bill
and one of the things
um is that this is a resolution
and a resolution is not law
and it in the bill
um
let me back up recognition is really
important
for our native Community
either state or federal
it is a step for reconciliation
uh
that had for Native communities that
have been subject to genocide violence
victimization exploitation Erasure by
the culture society and the government
at Large
reconciliation is serious
and it is an important endeavor
Federal recognition as we heard is a
different process and
it is
um
it achieves not only recognition but
specific benefits
it is my understanding that these two
desperate sovereignty processes are not
necessarily complementary or guaranteed
if you know if you have one you get the
other
it is a serious Endeavor State
sovereignty processes are codified in
law and they have implications to
different state agencies
um a resolution
as noted by your member representative
shurtleff this house resolution is
really only for the house
the Senate can doesn't necessarily sign
off on it they can if they decide to but
also resolution is not signed by the
governor
how is it actually recognition if the
governor the executive of the state
doesn't sign it
I I think this
um this is not recognition
and it does not have the weight of law
and it cannot provide a pathway to
achieve as it states in the bill greater
autonomy and local Authority
it can't do that
so instead
and I think Mr shirtleff was reading my
mind
um
you're right I think you're right
um uh to
uh full disclosure I live in his
district
um I I think
pursuing a pathway for recognition is
really what we want here that there are
other States including our neighbors to
the South uh and New York and and many
other states uh besides Vermont that
have gone through that do have state
recognition recognition processes
we also have the relevant state agencies
that would be involved you certainly
would want their feedback the commission
as it's been already
um
uh noted and there are experts at
Dartmouth and at UNH and at the other
universities in the in the State uh
Native American law is also a really
specialized and I think
um the state would the conversation
would benefit uh by having someone who
is an expert
um and and not to pass this resolution
at this time
but to to agree upon a goal to create a
pathway to recognize and and and have a
have a place to vet out to actually
categorize or or what was it the
characterize different
um the different groups uh
qualifications timelines at the
jurisdictions uh and and what to tell
the state agencies how to interact with
these none of that is provided in this
bill and and I just encourage the
committee
to recognize the the seriousness of of
recognition sorry saying that too much
um but to uh this is a series in Denver
and it has a lot of implications and it
is the right Pathway to take but this
may not be the right venue to take it so
with that I will conclude
would you take any questions if there
are any other any questions
we okay Shane and thank you for coming
all the way down from Pentacle yeah I
know I do have two more uh
cards uh I mentioned Carlos is here he
did not he's in opposition to the bill
and then I have one final card uh at
from um
love Lou Tut toughs more
and it's gonna call Carlos but it looks
like you're on the way so uh have a seat
have a seat uh you asked for two minutes
and you're you're coming from Bedford
Center Road and for the record if you
could just uh state your name
um in a better way than I did yes yes hi
um my name is Lev tafsamore
um and bear with me I've never done this
before
um but
I'm listening to everybody here
and I
I think
all my elders behind me have something
really important to say and I think I
can safely say I'm representing the
younger population of Abenaki indigenous
people
um and I just think that this bill is
incredibly important because
it just it gives it's all inclusive and
it gives everybody that needs credit
credit and
I live in New Hampshire but I work also
in California and I just think it's sort
of like
crazy how I can go out west and
you know my fellow native Community it's
like
they're all people know who's who and
it's like you come out here and it's
like oh wait you're native it's like
I didn't know there were people like you
here well absolutely so I think this is
an incredibly important bill to help
everybody and be all inclusive and also
I think it's gonna it says something for
my elders behind me and having their
voices heard and also says something for
us as young people like how am I going
to be able to explain things to my kids
how are they going to be able to explain
things to their kids
so I just hope and really ask people to
really really
listen to what the people are saying
because it's very valid and very
important
that's it thank you so much for stepping
up absolutely and speaking up would you
take any questions if there are any are
there any questions uh representative
O'Neill yes thank you for taking my
question
um and thank you for coming and speaking
today I think one of the common themes
we've been been hearing from the
different groups is that everyone agrees
that there should be some recognition
but there's a little differing in terms
of the mechanism for going about it with
some people speaking and talking about
how a commission would be with a formal
process might be more appropriate can
you just share how you how you feel on
that as opposed to this resolution
I have to admit I'm so overwhelmed by
everything here I'm not quite sure how
to answer your question and I want to be
very transparent and like say to you I'm
not quite sure how to answer your
question from my own personal life I'm
adopted and I recently just found out
that my birth family was one of the
stolen families on the east coast and my
family has been misplaced
how am I gonna explain that to my kids
how are other kids that are in my
situation or won't even have the luxury
of being in my situation gonna be able
to find that out
so I just feel like it's important that
everybody be all inclusive and
understand that everybody's life and
situation is different
and I feel like having this bill
is super important because it documents
children like me
thank you for that
other questions
Cena thank you again for for stepping up
and speaking out uh Belinda Sims has
some written testimony and had asked for
three minutes in
Melissa Melinda
welcome
that's what I'm here for
yeah
I'm sorry I can't face all of you
um
my name is Melinda Sims I'm from Belmont
New Hampshire I come to you today as a
concerned constituent a disabled veteran
a member of the Kawasaki band of the
Penacook Abenaki people and an
independent information researcher with
membership in The Association of
Independent information professionals
specializing in historical and
genealogical research in both the United
States and Canada for over 20 years
when I read HCR 7 it concerns me as
there are several discrepancies that
would not make this a simple bill
the following are the some of my
concerns no we've touched on a lot of
the the points but so I'll cut out some
of them but
um a couple I need to overlap
um the nelhegan ban has not appeared in
any documented indigenous historical
native prior narrative prior to 2004.
therefore they would not have standing
in our state all of the historical data
that the tribal applicants claim need to
be substantiated by a professional and
unbiased source and a historically
accurate manner
the Vermont act allows applicants to
self-declare which is concerning
Vermont's recognition act 107 is
deficient in its wording about the use
of a board certified genealogist to
properly vet the tribal applicants
genealogies
the ACT is also vague in requiring a
need for unbiased third-party expert
veters that are not akin to the tribal
applicants
we should not blindly accept Vermont's
critically flawed tribal recognition
process
there should be a clear and impartial
vetting process by an outside
professional source for all historical
and genealogical data that is presented
by any tribal applicant
Vermont's recognition act 107 also
prohibits any tribe from being
recognized as a tribal group in any
other state Province or Nation putting
forward a recognition bill or resolution
such as this one
is in direct violation of the Vermont
recognition process and is strictly
prohibited so it's perplexing to me as
to why this band would request
recognition in New Hampshire too
Vermont's recognition act 107 States it
will assist the Native American Indian
tribes recognized by the state to secure
assistance for social services education
employment opportunities so on and so
forth
New Hampshire should not be offering
benefits to outside tribal organizations
already recognized in another state if
the band were to be recognized in New
Hampshire wouldn't that be double
dipping in benefits
personally I'm flabbergasted that a bill
to recognized a Vermont band has come
before this legislature especially
knowing that there are bans right here
in New Hampshire that have never been
recognized
I find this disrespectful to all our
indigenous New Hampshire cons
constituents
and if this should go forward I think it
would be shameful
thank you very much for your time
thank you for hanging in there for a
couple hours
and questions do you would you take any
questions if there are any
and seeing none
oh I'm sorry uh yeah yes uh
representative
uh thank you for taking my question
um could you provide uh your written
testimony for the committee as well you
already have yes okay thank you all
right thank you
and thank you yes the card had indicated
you had written testimony which we
appreciated we've got a plenty to to go
through on this on this measure
final pink card is uh Carlos Cardona has
been here before
the uh
the issue on Puerto Rico we had a
hearing on we'll be executing that this
afternoon uh Carlos but you're here for
to oppose HCR 7.
I am uh thank you uh chairperson and
committee for hearing me out once more
in this committee it's always great to
see you all
state representatives
I just said Thank you for having me
today good day also I wanted to say my
presence is my resistance my language is
my freedom thank you for allowing me to
speak today
my name is Carlos Enrique Cardona LeBron
I am a member of the higuayagua tribe
and I should acknowledge it's not an
indigenous tribe to the state of New
Hampshire as an indigenous tribe to the
Caribbean part of the Taino family but I
I should also note that there are 17 000
boricuas tainos here in the state of New
Hampshire much larger than some other
indigenous groups in the state so if
we're going to start a resolution by
acknowledging United States tribe
perhaps we should start by some of the
larger tribes that exist here in the
state
um I also want to mention that I am a
member of the New Hampshire Commission
on Native American Affairs appointed by
Governor Chris sununu I also here have
written testimonies yesterday the
commission met we did not have a quorum
due to some unforeseen events so we were
not able to vote on how we feel as a
commission but it is safe to say that
out of 12 members only nine of them are
voting members
which nine testimonies opposing this
resolution including the chairperson of
the commission a new New Hampshire
native American Affairs I should also
note that every single one of these
members has been appointed yes please
thank you representative uh every single
one of these uh Commissioners members of
the commission on New Hampshire native
American Affairs has also been appointed
by our current Governor Chris sununu
uh but of course I am here for myself as
a private citizen and I'm just
facilitating to provide you the
testimonies of my colleagues I am from
Laconia New Hampshire and I should know
and acknowledge the brothers and sisters
from the Kawasaki band who have been the
Guardians of many of our lands that we
live in today I am asking you today to
please vote against the resolution I
truly believe that this resolution
discriminates against all other
indigenous people living here in the
state of New Hampshire I also have
concerns about this resolution not
having the best interests of the State
of New Hampshire or the people that live
here as a young indigenous person I
would also like to see a proper form or
method in the state to recognizing
tribes and Indigenous people but this is
not one of them this leaves out many
cows it leaves many bands
and tribes that we should be
acknowledging
I believe in inclusion and this
resolution fails to do just that while
allowing another state to dictate to us
who we should recognize and who should
be representing our indigenous people I
also find it quite disturbing that a
state representative would use their
power to sponsor a resolution while
leaving out other indigenous people and
only representing their personal
interest
thank you gracias jahon
happy to take any questions
a question would you you said you would
take questions are there any questions
uh representative shortlist
thank you Mr chairman and it's so nice
to have you back with us again
um you mentioned that you serve on the
commission would the commission be
offended if
if we retain this bill instead of us
doing something came out with the bill
to ask for a study commission to look at
this whole issue of recognition of
Native Americans in this state would
that be offensive to the members of the
commission
I have no authority to speak on behalf
of the commission but it would be
offensive to me and I think you can see
very clearly that other members that I'm
associated with
um would finally find it highly
offensive keep in mind this commission
is very diverse there are two tainos
there are two of pretty much every
single tribe that resides here in the
state of New Hampshire with the
exception of the tribe that is looking
to get recognition because they decided
before my time on the commission to
resign that I believe that was in 2021
so I believe that you know it would be
very highly offensive to myself and
other people that uh believed in
recognizing uh tribes that are from here
from the state of New Hampshire
follow-up Mr chair follow up
then who or whom should be the ones to
formulate
a commission to be able to vet Native
Americans it seems like this has been
going on for some time and there's a lot
of confusion a lot of different players
and everything else but who should bring
everybody together to come up with
something uh that we can all be proud of
and give the recognition to a New
Hampshire Native Americans that they
deserve and they if who
I I love this question and I appreciate
it I do want to give you some context
and uh this past fall Governor Chris
tanunu made a proclamation recognizing
Abenaki people's day
um including basically all Abenaki
people in the state of New Hampshire
which I thought was very inclusive
um I have a little bit of a problem
about presentation but that's between me
and the governor that's a whole
different question
um but he also recognized the New
Hampshire native American commission
which is also appointed by him and I
think that is a step forward I also
believe that this commission should have
more ability and more say and more power
in this process and perhaps the State
House can have instead of this
resolution that has no teeth and causes
more problems and headaches then it
actually resolves or create any Unity
amongst people I believe that the state
house could easily fix this by giving
some teeth to the commission the
commission is already there why reinvent
the wheel and it took a long time for
this commission to get recognition
Denise and Paul had worked very hard
amongst other their members for many
years to get this recognized so it is a
step forward the mechanism is there we
just have to give it some teeth perhaps
there's a law that we can pass where it
gives some legal recognition to this
commission too because right now it's
just an Advisory Board essentially to
the governor
so my thoughts are this is something
that very much the State House can fix
but this is not the way to do it by
starting with one group that really is
from another state yeah and that wasn't
my issue it was the Native American
people as a whole without one particular
and I also believe that you know this
Commission
perhaps the the easy solution so that
one tribe doesn't have more power over
another it's making a crystal clear that
only two members of each tribe could uh
could be part of this commission I
believe that there could be a future
bill that it's in the in its way to you
all which it would completely wipe
um the commission as it stands today the
commission is I have to tell you from my
experience I'm the youngest by 40 years
and I'm the only one probably in their
30s in that commission it's very
respectful I think that it the
representation that we got earlier about
being toxic I find it offensive I've
learned a lot from these individuals and
the respect that they have for me which
my tribe is not even native to the state
of New Hampshire it has been profound
and touching and my people experience
paper genocide so I believe that the
process is there to recognize one
another the commission works very
efficiently even with having no teeth so
I believe that you know you guys have a
good path forward this resolution is
just not one of them well maybe we can
truck more offline I am happy to launch
anytime
I'll even buy thank you other questions
uh website
um yeah I was just wondering do you see
if there is a particular con conflict of
interest with this particular piece of
legislation thank you representative
sieber
um yeah I do believe that there is a
conflict of interest I mean I believe
that representative Finney was on to it
earlier within regards to my one of my
favorite Senators Senator Bernie Sanders
um and his ear Mark
um you know this is something that
happens a lot in individual states I
have a problem with that and what kind
of cost this resolution could have for
future Generations here in the state of
New Hampshire and as somebody who is
proud of making sure that our state
fights for its own rights and having no
federal government infringement on our
rights I find it really troubling what
kind of implications this uh this
resolution could have for future it may
not have any legal binding at the moment
but in the future it could be uzx
context to recognize one at tribe that
has very little record history and two
um it could hurt other tribes here in
the state of New Hampshire so perhaps a
better resolution with that it's more
inclusive that gives all the tribes here
in the state of New Hampshire uh it's
best and And in regards to that I also
want to highlight this representative
that submitted this resolution has the
same ability to include all the tribes
you know not too long ago representative
Peter Schmidt did a resolution including
my people of Puerto Rico she could have
done the exact same thing he's not
Puerto Rican he's white he's from here
from the state of New Hampshire and he
included my people so there's no reason
why representative Sherry couldn't have
included even without the consent just
to recognize simply the other tribes
that are here in the state of New
Hampshire so I think any state
representative can do that there's a lot
of conflicts with this resolution
I find it highly offensive are there any
other questions
thank you again for being here I have
two more pink cars that have come this
way
um
Rod Sims has asked for three minutes and
David peesley has asked for two minutes
is Rod uh that must be rod and Rod is
from nine Sargent Street I don't know
what municipality that is Mr Sergeant
but you'll Mr Sims you'll tell us though
right yeah I'm from Belmont New
Hampshire I'm my uh my wife spoke
earlier I'm her caretaker that's why I
showed up today but my wife and I have
been married for 12 years and when we
did our e-harmony thing she really
didn't speak about how vested she was in
the uh indigenous Affairs of New
Hampshire after I married her I found
out that there's been a turmoil going on
in this state for quite some time
there's a lot of different bands that
have never seemed to come together and
have a united front it kind of puts I'm
from Ohio and where I'm from in Ohio
there's a lot of neighborhood gangs and
even though we live in the same town
everybody's got the head of that gang
and they could never come together and
have a peaceful conversation about
something that was always Division and I
see that a lot here and as this
resolution is written I I oppose it I
think it actually brings in more uh
strife and controversy than what already
exists amongst tribes here and I I would
be for a committee or something formed
that everybody could have representation
on and everybody could come to an
agreement on and hopefully get something
done in New Hampshire that would help
unite the tribes and the different
peoples that are here because right now
it just there's a lot of division a lot
of people are there's angst and instead
of uniting they're they're kind of like
opposed to each other and I definitely
before if if something could be started
to where some committee could be formed
and there's been some people that's far
more educated on this than I am talking
about this but I'm like a Outsider just
seeing what's going on so I think I
think that people want something they're
just not sure exactly how to go about it
and how to make it fair for everybody
here
thank you for that I think that goes a
little bit to what representative
shurtleff uh suggested we look at
considering question would you take any
questions are there and are there any
questions
thank you for coming out from Belmont
and for all that you do and uh David
peesley from Hopkinton is in the house
asked for two minutes he's in support of
this measure
that's my lousy handwriting it's Daryl
Peasley but
I wasn't going to speak but I've been
sitting here listening
and I'm going to tell you the facts
right up front it doesn't matter what
you do you are not going to please
everyone that's in this room whether you
hold it you retain it you kill it
you give us a golden buzzer someone is
going to be upset that's native politics
for you
um
I am the registered state agent for
Abenaki helping Abenaki
through our tribal nonprofit I'm also a
melhegan citizen
so our mission is to help everyone
this resolution was supposed to be a
stepping stone for others
and as soon as I started seeing all the
different stuff on your portal here we
go
it's going to be us against them and
that's the way they're going to portray
it
working on the bill to get that the
commission and Native American Affairs
established
then I became one of the original
members I served two terms the last term
was the vice chair
been off the commission for a long time
I decided
it was time to get back on the
commission to represent my people they
had four or five vacancies so I asked
the question online on their Facebook
page and I can still go back and get it
if you pull it up to date it was a year
later before I got a response from
anybody
and then the response was you already
served your two terms so I contacted the
Attorney General's office
and they said that commission's like any
other commission as long as you're off
for a full term you can reapply
so that's I did
um two years I got strung along
and I was not gonna count out anything
they wanted me to do
um
pretty ugly
I was I was when people asked why I
wasn't back on the commission
one of the commission members who was
still a commission member told everyone
that I was under investigation
for lying the governor's office was
investigating me well anyone that knows
anything knows the governor's office
doesn't investigate anything the
Attorney General's office investigates
I inquired I filed the 91a request there
is no such investigation
so and then it the rumor was going
around that well Daryl didn't get put
back on the commission because the
governor didn't want him on there
because he was found out he was lying he
was under investigation
so contact the governor's office didn't
get a response because it's just Betty
and it and to me it sounds very Petty
very childish I wanted to know why
someone's saying something about me I
even hired an attorney
um almost came that close
so anyways I contacted the director of
cultural natural resources
he was only honest one that I came
across
um my application I've went to the
governor's office because the commission
members didn't want me on the commission
and to this day I've never gotten a
response back from them as to we're not
going to entertain your application this
is the reason why so on and so forth
the reason the other two nohegan people
got off the commission is because it was
starting to affect their Mental Health
um
it may not be that way now
but it sure was
a couple years ago
there were there were many vacancies on
the commission
and just recently the governor started
applying uh appointing quite a few
people
but
so anyways I don't want you to feel bad
that geez I'm trying to please Daryl I'm
trying to please Don I'm trying to
please Paul I'm trying to police Denise
never gonna happen
I don't care how you do it I don't care
if you give me a check for a thousand
dollars right now and I can disperse it
they're still not going to be happy
because they're getting recognition I'm
not getting recognition it's oh my God
I'm a chief and
the other thing is I hope you do your
research a lot of research
because most of what has been testified
to today at the very beginning at least
yeah I I want to stay positive I don't
want to so anyways thank you if you have
any questions I'll be more than happy to
I just couldn't sit by and
it's irritating are there any questions
representative uh Gagney
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question it's actually it's uh
more of a would you believe that
what I've the testimony I've heard here
this morning
is like
two close-knit families arguing
over uh over whatever
and and you know that just bugs the heck
out of me so bear with us I hope that we
can do a commission or something to get
down the bottom of this and settle it
one way or the other
thank you representative yes we will be
very much well or much better informed
by the time we exact this a week from
today uh we have a lot of new stuff
material here to look at and thank you
for your candor it takes the pressure
off knowing that we're not going to make
everyone happy
other questions
seeing none that is our last pink card
for this session which ran just a little
bit over the scheduled time but uh we
appreciate the people coming in and
helping us to get smarter and better
informed on this that obviously is
important I like to ask the uh
committees and dozens I want to we have
three more measures that I I don't
anticipate taking uh two and a half
hours each uh but you never know how
many pink cars will come in disruption
of Belcher in the house
he is not
um uh rep
well I what I wanted to do is I see the
prime sponsor for HR 16 is now so what
we're going to do is we've adjourned the
uh hearing on hcr7 I'm going to uh start
the hearing on HR 15.
uh I'm gonna recess the hearing on HR 15
briefly and I'm going to go right to HR
16 because the the sole representative
the sole sponsor is here
uh representative Gerhard so I'm going
to ask a couple of Gerhard to introduce
uh H.R 16.
um right now so uh
um yes represent Manion is is so he's uh
they're doing an exact session right now
and he said to message him and not to go
yeah but so I let him know okay so we
have a plan we're good yeah
uh so
representative whenever you're ready
you up a little bit uh but you're here
can we have order in the room please
yes uh
yes
give us another minute uh representative
Gerhard and we'll be ready for you
now we've already recessed 15 we're
we're doing 16 and um
we're on 16. uh HR 16 representative
Belgium thank you uh we uh started you
here and we recessed it to take H.R 16
so uh you have a little bit of time if
you need it
um we don't anticipate this will take as
long as HCR 7.
so uh that said at this time we'll
recognize the prime sponsor or the
sponsor of HR 16 representative Gearhart
from Merrimack County uh welcome
representative Gerhard thank you
chairman
thank you members of the committee for
hearing this my name is Jason Gerhard
represent Northfield Franklin
and H.R 16 is very simple it poses three
questions to the IRS which they have
never satisfactorily answered and which
would put money into everybody's pocket
in the state that pays into that
fraudulent tax so I'm going to break it
down real fast to three questions
where is the word income defined in the
Internal Revenue code that's the first
one second where in the Internal Revenue
code is it written that the average
American who does not exercise a federal
privilege but simply trades their time
for money is liable to pay the federal
income tax and lastly why have numerous
Internal Revenue Service Publications
directors and members of the United
States Congress among others stated that
the income tax is voluntary
the
to really look into this
well this book is awesome but
it's all based on terms of art or
specialized definitions of commonly used
words inside the code so I'm just going
to go real fast just two of them maybe
three
so first off Supreme Court quote U.S
verse Ballard in 1976 quote the general
term income is not defined in the
Internal Revenue code
now you guys don't have this I didn't
make up a whole paper but I'll email you
everything just so I'll give you all the
citations in an email so you don't have
to worry about that so now with the
definitions of the actual words
as I said before I've considered their
term they're called terms of art we have
in section 3401 definitions wages
and employee so wages for purpose of
this chapter the term wages means all
remuneration other than fees paid to a
public official for services performed
by an employee for his employer then we
look now to see for employee for
purposes of this chapter the term
employee includes an officer employee or
elected official United States a state
or any political subdivision thereof or
the District of Columbia or any agency
or instrumentality or anyone more of the
foregoing the term employee also
includes an officer of a corporation and
then it goes into a whole bunch of stuff
and it's not normal corporations but the
point is it's all based off of this
legalese maze work that no one
understands so all I'm asking you to do
well to OTP this but to get this to the
floor we pass it and we just asked some
questions which I think we as
taxpayers of this country are entitled
to I mean the code is something like 66
or 70 I don't know it's thousands of
pages long no one understands it so hey
we'll just start with these three
questions get an understanding move on
down the road and then we'll all be
better off
that's kind of the basic gist of where I
wanted to go I mean we can look at
the definition of trade or business just
to show you how this is not
um just relegated to those two words I
just didn't want to go on and on and on
so
this is another in section 7701
Trader business the term Trader business
includes the performance of the
functions of a public office and just so
you know in the IRS code in in legalese
the word includes isn't like how we
think of it includes is only those items
so it's not as in you know apples and
oranges includes all fruit it's
they're simply those apples and oranges
of what's being discussed I don't know
if that makes any sense I'm probably not
doing a good job but first time kind of
doing his life but it's just an it's
it's a very personal topic to me because
there's people doing multiple decades in
prison for the supposed crime of not
funding the war machine in DC via the
federal income taxes which if you really
want to get into it none of the money
from the federal income tax actually
goes anywhere besides paying off the
interest on a national debt which we can
never pay off so the whole thing is a
waste of time but the uh the issue at
hand right now are these three questions
so I would appreciate actually just if
you have any questions I know this is
all technicality stuff I really don't
want to get into that so much because if
you look into it I think you'll be able
but
um I'll do as best I can in the short
period of time we have so
that's my testimony thank you
thank you representative uh on line 11
it's you state where in the Internal
Revenue code is it written that the
average American who does not exercise a
federal privilege but simply trades in
their time for money is liable to pay
the federal income tax
um as I understand it's not a matter of
code it's the constitution in 1913 we
passed an amendment that that uh made
the personal income tax part of the
Constitution isn't that where it comes
from not code but the Constitution
got some highlighted passages for you
right here don't worry so thank you
chairman and two this is in PEC versus
low the 16th Amendment although referred
to an argument has no real bearing and
may be put out of view as pointed out in
recent decisions it does not extend the
taxing power to new or accepted subjects
but middleware moves All Occasion which
otherwise might exist for an
importionment among the states of taxes
laid on income whether it's derived from
One Source or another so what happened
was let me read this other quote that
was a little bit it's prefers something
previously the provision the provisions
this is from uh hovering versus Edison
Brothers the provisions of the 16th
Amendment conferred no new power of
taxation but simply prohibited the
complete and plenary power of income
taxation possessed by Congress from the
beginning from being taken out of the
category of indirect taxation to which
it inherently belonged so let me explain
I know it's a whole bunch of mixes
actually that's Stanton versus Baltic
mining but
what we have going on is the federal
government has two ways to tax us
well let's say to tax the people of the
country right you have apportionment and
then you have direct taxation direct
taxation occurs through excise taxes
Alcohol Tobacco basically things you
don't need right those can be taxed at
the direct level apportionment has to do
with you New Hampshire owes the federal
government million dollars and there's a
million people here hypothetically
everybody is one dollar you can't say to
one person twenty percent five percent
here's free money it just doesn't that's
the Constitutional position the 16th
Amendment didn't change any of that it
simply allowed the federal government to
tax people who are deriving benefits
from owning stocks in companies that
dealt with the federal government so
when I say exercise a federal privilege
that is basically if you sell guns to
the military or something of that nature
the simple trading of your time
for someone else's money has nothing to
do with the federal government if it was
it'd be slavery because let's think
about it I work an eight-hour day I'm on
a 25 let's say uh income tax rate
two hours of my day now we're going to
the federal government
agreed does it make sense so how is it
that the federal government has a claim
on 25 of my time or two hours of my
labor
that's
so I can be enslaved for 20 you know for
two hours a day
that's that's the issue
we're asking you the questions but when
you when you ask that question uh it's
in a rhetorical sense correct of course
I'm just yeah I I'm not going to claim
to be some expert I'm a carpenter all I
know is from I'm on more of a blue
collar kick with this I just want to
know where in the code they're I'm sorry
yeah where in the code they're claiming
all of these rights to do this then we
can have a further discussion I'm not
claiming to be an expert all I know is
they've played a massive game of hide
and seek for way too long and I think
it's time to just get these basic
concepts out there I just I hate when we
get really caught up in the weeds of the
legalese I think every person in this
country should a understand the
Constitution Declaration of Independence
end this supposed monstrosity that
enslaves us to it for at least two hours
a day or whatever you want to call it
depending on where your tax rate is
are there other questions
we would appreciate if you could get the
clerk a uh pink card for HIV so many
people in there I forgot thank you and
uh we would ask that
and I would ask the Indulgence of the
committee the I'm gonna
adjourn thank you I'm gonna adjourn the
hearing on HR 16 and I'm gonna go back
to HR 15 the prime sponsor is uh right
here in the house and uh as soon as we
finish this hearing however long it
takes we will take a break we have one
more uh HR on the docket
um that we'll address after a break
after
we do HR 15. so welcome representative
belsher glad you're here thank you for
your flexibility I know this was
scheduled for 10 15 and it's now 12 15.
so thank you for your flexibility and
welcome thank you Mr chair and members
of the committee for for hearing my bill
and first let me offer some apologies
for submitting what's probably one of
the longer and more dense bills that
you've had to
resolutions rather that you've had to
look through
um however I I do assure you that it was
unfortunately necessary to to be such
so let's first
set the stage for what this is about
um
our founder is when this country was
brand new and they were deliberating on
how they were going to set up this
government they had come from a time not
so long ago where the church of England
had had significant ties to the
government of England they were
effectively the same thing and the
church was exercising civil Authority
and that is something that they
very much wanted to put a stop to which
is why we find in the First Amendment to
the Constitution the prohibition on the
formation of a state Church
and the non-establishment of religion
so that's what I am going to be
appealing to here
so the argument that I need to make and
that I'd like you to keep an open mind
to
is that Marxism itself
and the various ideologies that stem
from it are in fact not
um philosophy not economics
but actually a religious Dogma
so let's
Loosely Define what a religion is here
so religion
is a system of faith it is a number of
different ideas that people hold
about the way the world Works about what
it means to be alive what it means to be
human the nature of Consciousness and
also importantly ideas such as ethical
doctrines where do ethics come from why
should I not simply hurt somebody why
should somebody not simply hurt me these
are basic questions that when combined
those separately perhaps philosophical
but when combined these become elements
of a religious system
um and just to help uh Define here when
it says historicism I will quickly
Define that word uh historicism is not
the same thing as history historicism is
an ideology or a facet of religious
belief that suggests that there is a
particular path that history is moving
on
um perhaps being driven that way by a
spirit of History you could say and it
has a end point that is predetermined
and it's heading to that point and for
instance Christianity has a a bit of a
historicist nature to it and that
Christianity believes that there will be
a second coming of Christ
leading to the reinstantiation of
um essentially Eden
well likewise Marxism has this same
historicist bent flowing through it in
that I believe his history is
progressing toward an in-state a utopian
in state
um and the utopianism of this is very
very important to understand
because a lot of people when they when
they see marks they think Das Capital an
economic theory but let me tell you that
economic theories do not end in heaven
that's not how when economic theory
Works ideas that lead you to a
heaven-like utopian future that is
prophesied
that's religious in nature
so moving on from there
Marxism presents many different claims
about metaphysics Human Experience
the nature of human agency the nature of
Consciousness and ethics
Marxism tends to view everything through
what they call the oppressor oppressed
dialectic this Theory goes back a very
long ways
Marx got the idea from Hegel through
reading his book phenomenology of spirit
and studying that and being a young
hegelian which is a sort of an occultist
Gnostic and hermeticist movement that
was popular very popular actually in
Europe and in America from the mid-1800s
through the early 1900s
Hegel took his dialectic from can't
can't took his dialectic from presumably
Plato So this stuff goes back a very
very long ways
when Marx made his claim to have a
theory for Scientific Socialism that's
capital S science
we have to make a
bit of a detour to the history of the
word science
science has not always meant what we
consider science to be we consider
science to be an investigative tool
typically when we think of it but
especially in Germany at the time
science more generally just meant a
knowledge and they generally broke it
down into two types of science you had
regular science which was investigative
which they did not think very highly of
and then they had another science Hegel
referred to the as the science of reason
and this was a metaphysical science that
was concerned with making prophecies
about the end of the world and how we
get there
again this is a this is a religious
Dogma
let's see here moving on
so this this document and I won't go
through this entire thing I'm sure you
have time to to read it but I want to
highlight the important parts of this
because
by the way the Supreme Court has defined
previously religion and they've defined
it in a very similar manner that I have
up at the top here as far as giving rise
to duties of conscience and ethics if
you've ever heard the term being on the
right side of History
that term actually comes from the idea
of a historicist Doctrine where history
is heading in the correct direction and
you have to be on the right side of it
because at history they actually believe
there will be sort of a in a manetized
God that will look back and judge you
similarly again to Christianity where
you will be judged at the end of History
again this is religious ideology
[Music]
so let's talk for a minute about the
some of the different denominations or
branches of Marxism and how this
developed over time
original Marxism would have obviously
begun with Marx early Marx even before
his Das Capital book
from there it moved on
to
from Germany to the U.S
through Hitler's rise as Hitler Rose to
power many of the Communists in Germany
fled of course they were they were being
attacked
some of them settled here in America
some of them in New York they formed a
school where they began sort of
retooling Marx's theology because Marx
had a prophecy that the dictatorship of
the proletariat would arise and this is
again this is a this is a prophecy this
is not an economic theory a dictator of
the proletariat would arise overthrow
the existing order and install
ultimately communism
that's the sequence of events that
didn't happen
so much like the preacher who says Jesus
is coming back next week and he gets his
disciples together
and they have a party and it doesn't
happen there was much disappointment
among the Communists that it didn't
happen so they had to go back to the
drawing board and figure out why did
this not happen
at this point through the Institute of
social research AKA The Frankfurt School
these marxists retooled his theory from
the original sort of quasi-economic
theory and they refocused it onto the
onto more identity characteristics
such as race because what you'll learn
through the history of Marxism is that
it always attacks something that's real
it finds a real fault in society and it
seeks to exploit it
so when Marx exploited capitalism as he
called it he was exploiting real
economic problems in America there were
real race problems and that is what they
sought to exploit by shifting things in
that direction and applying what again
the dialectic
from there the theory went on
um to become even even more centered on
race and other identity functions
through some of the work of
um for instance Kimberly Crenshaw uh her
work on critical race Theory
um
let's see Kimberly Crenshaw goes on to
the gender theorist Judith Butler and
some of the others and what are these
are is there are different applications
of the of the Gen of the the original
Marxist dialectic to different identity
Dimensions sex race
and what these actually constitute are
different denominations within the
broader Church of Marxism just like
Christianity will have you know
Protestants and Catholics are kind of
the big two that compete even within
protestantism you've got methodists
you've got Baptist you've got
Presbyterians you've got all these
different denominations they don't
always agree on everything
this is the same thing throughout
history there are splits in the church
and they go on to have disagreements
about things
so skipping on a little bit here
some of the biggest problems with what
we're facing right now that are a part
of this Doctrine are ideas that deeply
conflict with what our founding fathers
put in place
ideas like you actually need to
attribute malice and Wrongs and
punishments
to People based on things like class or
gender or race not what those actual
people did but what some other person or
some historical context related to their
identity did
and that that is not something the
founding fathers ever would have gone
for
see
um so
I guess I'll wrap it up with this
this is not some
crackpot idea this is Cutting Edge stuff
there are a lot of people who are coming
to this same conclusion looking at the
history of what has happened here and
where we find ourselves now this is
being advanced in other places there is
a similar resolution that is happening
at the federal level along these not
exact lines but similar lines
and I would be happy to
take any questions on that
thank you for offering to take questions
uh I have one
on page two at the bottom uh actually
the very last two last two lines 36 and
37 uh it's it resolve after all the
whereas is it says resolved by the House
of Representatives
um it refers to a complete faith system
which which I I get that with Doctrine
Dogma ritual thesaurus Theory but the
the word spirits and Magic
um I think people are going to want to
have you explain that better
Spirit what spirits and Magic are
associated with Marxist yes I'd be
absolutely happy to so as I said this
this ideology and these ideas this
Theology and theosophy theosophy being
the combining of multiple religions
which is what has really happened here
goes back a very long time and at the
root of the what you would call the
dialectic as Hegel applied it is
actually hermetic Alchemy
and hermetic Alchemy is an idea it is it
is a very deep religious system that was
competing with early Christianity
it is a concept that God created the
world poured himself into the world he
overflowed into the world but he created
the world because he didn't know himself
and it is only through the actions of
people through creating things and
understanding them that God then
understands himself and at the end of
History
he recognizes himself to be God that's
the that's sort of the Baseline
hermeticist idea now throughout history
especially throughout the Dark Ages
there were various what you might call
Magic rituals surrounding this if you've
heard of alchemy this idea of turning
base Metals into gold
there is a lot of similar things
happening here
um with even even some of the modern
stuff but they've they've changed the
nature of it over time so whereas they
would often try to literally turn lead
into gold early on now they're they're
concerned with this idea that the Utopia
Lies Beneath all that currently exists
so you have to destroy all that
currently exists to get to that Utopia
and they have to go through rituals of
purification rituals of of
um if you've ever heard of a maoist
struggle session this idea of denying
that you have these beliefs these
reactionary beliefs this is actually a
ritual it's a ritual of of purifying
yourself
um and that's that's part of the when I
say magic I don't mean they have literal
magic they're not it comes down to that
and it also comes down to what Catholic
philosopher uh Joseph peeper called the
abusive language the abuse of power and
they actually through the manipulation
of language
um can keep people confused about what's
going on
and we see a lot of that as well so
that's that's what I mean by um rituals
and Magic
thank you for that other questions
representative Finney
I have a few if
um if you'll indulge me
um and thank you for I'm being here to
speak on this issue so
it sounds like and
um I'm gonna say this I'm gonna try to
say this so this bill is essentially an
anti-uh this establishmentarianism bill
correct
anti
disestablishmentarianism yep can you
define that so it's it's against the
establishment of any
um
Chinese establishmentarianism so it's
like a it's like a philosophy uh just
based on not allowing the state to
establish cultural and uh societal ideas
so I what I would say is it's really
so there's there's the the truth about
the bill the idea behind the bill the
philosophical foundation of the bill is
that
um these things are correct and I've put
them down on paper and I believe that
are true the Practical side of the bill
is that I believe that the way they've
been implemented today in in government
and in education these ideas are
violative of the first amendment's
protection from being forced to
participate in the religious practices
that you don't hold or the religion that
you don't hold it's a it's a violation
of individual liberties and rights and
it's also a violation of the very nature
of the way this country was set up to
have as I said these metaphysical
presuppositions you have to go all the
way down to your deepest beliefs in
order to examine things like why do we
believe that the innocent should be
proven or should be innocent until
proven guilty instead of just being
called guilty because of the color of
their skin or their class and we've seen
these things throughout history happen
time and time again
follow up one follow-up
well I only get one okay
well at least one I only have two left
is that okay
two follow-ups thank you I appreciate it
so I want to just to get some
clarification on the on the the the way
I'm framing my question here and and I
will say for the record that um I am an
outspoken atheist and I think it's
important that we do uphold uh The
Establishment Clause of the First
Amendment because
um it is not appropriate for religion to
be included and you know in any
government proceeding so I ask you
though is it the role of government to
affirm or deny the acceptance of of
subjectively unpopular ideas
uh in the way that that that we would
try to control a narrative some way or
try to gatekeep people from believing in
what they believe in
uh let me break that apart into two
different tracks so first the Supreme
Court has already previously established
precedent defining
um what a religion would be
um so the the idea that we would try to
impose a definition of religion onto
this
um we would be looking at Supreme Court
precedent but for a more generalist
perspective
I believe that as a as a group of people
who use language none of us individually
own language you can't no no individual
person can say well this isn't that
because I don't believe it's that it's
it's sort of a
language and stab is an established
thing that has consistent meaning over
time or it ceases to be useful
um so in that context yes I do believe
it's perfectly appropriate to call
something like this religion even if
somebody might disagree who believes
these things
um the other if you remind me what the
the last party question was so I can
um is it the role of government to
subjectively
um affirm or deny the acceptance or
denial of of you know Society cultural
ideas okay so on that one there's
nothing in in this resolution whatsoever
that would call for the government to
restrict the religious practice of
Marxism nothing whatsoever it just says
that because it is a religious practice
it can't be forced on other people
through government okay and my last
question
um so we're talking about the
marketplace of ideas correct
um and we're trying to to retain what we
do in these bills to what's happening in
our state do you personally find and I
would you know assume yes but we could
argue the point but are you finding that
in New Hampshire the representative
style of government that we're having is
being eroded in favor of a you know
socialist or Marxist or communist
function of government because the way
that I see it I think that we are
permanently
um in defense with representative style
that we already have in New Hampshire
and I and I would I would ask do you you
know feel that that we're you know
getting
um to the point where we would see some
type of major overhaul I I find that
hard to to actually believe yes thank
you um so I would direct you to page two
beginning at lines 21 and I'll read just
a little bit here whereas Marxism seeks
equity in the forcible dismantling or
inverting of all dialectical hierarchies
and power dynamics forcible
redistribution of power resources and
property and intentional Affliction of
Repertory injury along collectivist
lines those to those oppressor groups
further goes on it talks similarly about
diversity
authentic Justice and these terms so if
you look
and you apply these terms to what we see
currently in in government yes this this
uh this state in the executive branch
has a diversity equity and inclusion
Council that has had significant impact
over how this government works and these
are as I demonstrate here I think in
totality these are religious Concepts
that are being imposed on people
other questions
I just want to make one comment on line
27 you refer to the emanitization of the
estacion and then and I read a lot and I
gotta be honest I need to do some
homework on some of this language
representative uh but I I thank you for
bringing this forward I
you may hear from me and some of the
rest of us during the coming week for
some clarification on some of this sure
which we will exactly what that is if
you'd like just real quick okay
Matt so to manage the ashketan the
ashketon is this is this idea that at
the end of history or at the end of some
series of events is going to be an end
of the world or an end of the current
ERA end of the current time where we
transition into a whole different
Paradigm so that's a religious concept
and to emanitize it means to bring it
about
um so it's it's kind of like if if in
Christianity without getting in depth
post-millennials might believe that you
can actually cause Christ to come back
after by establishing a Thousand-Year
rule
so that would be a practice trying to
manetize the ash Katana similarly
marxists believe they have to do the
work of Marxism to to eliminate all the
contradictions of the dialectic in order
to monetize the ashkan or bring about
the end of history and enter the Utopia
thank you it's very interesting to me
you'll probably hear from me again
during this coming week I'm going to
read this and read it again and you may
hear from some of the rest of us as well
you'll be happy you have one co-sponsor
any other questions for the prime
sponsor uh representative is it
representative
that's representative LaMontagne yes
representative LaMontagne please and
thank you for taking my question
um it seems to me that you're asking us
to
Define a political philosophy as a
religion
where you haven't necessarily heard from
people who made them calls themselves
marxists that they themselves believe
that they are a religion
and if you're doing this couldn't this
not be applied
to people who believe other political
theories that may
um say capitalism that may also believe
their political and economic system
results in many other benefits to
society that might also be con conceived
of as having
a religious perspective or end game
whatever you might call it and aren't
you worried that
um
you know you may have unintended
consequences thank you thank you very
much for the question and that's a very
important question
um so going back to the Supreme Court
the Supreme Court has established
precedent for a number of different
items that must be met before something
can be properly considered according to
them anyway a religious Doctrine
um so you can't you can't necessarily
just take a political ideology and say
because this political ideology believes
that it's a religion there has to be a
whole host of different things going on
there has to be there has to be an
ethical system that gives rise to duties
of conscience there has to be concepts
of historicism or a
um or an end times theory that go along
with it
um to give you to give you a quote that
helps support
um some of that for instance one of the
I believe it was Herbert Marcus one of
the Frankfurt School marxists said
um communism is exactly the religion
that must overthrow Christianity in the
West
um so there may be some disagreement
among marxists or Communists but some of
them clearly and many of them throughout
history have believed it to be uh
religion and just to make a point on the
last thing and I love bringing this up
because it it's really interesting
uh capitalism is actually a term that
was coined by marxists
um and it's not really something that
exists because capitalism within the
Marxist or ideology theology is a system
that perpetuates itself through a
magical property called Capital it's not
what we normally think of as capital
like cash it has a magical property to
it that self-perpetuates over time in
order to keep the oppressed down
and so there's actually a magical idea
that goes along with that
um so what we have is is free markets or
we I wish we had free markets rather but
um it isn't technically capitalism
because capitalism is a Marxist concept
with metaphysical underpinnings that
just can't be escaped
other questions
thank you again representative thank you
very much and at this time we will call
a uh an adjourman to that particular
hearing now we have one more item on our
uh
on our um I see a pink card
and this is for
okay
okay so uh when I was looking to do was
now that uh representative Petrino is
here he's asked for just two minutes to
introduce this measure uh and then I'm
looking to recess uh from this measure a
second time and we'll come back at 1 30
to to finish uh any discussion or
anything else on this after you
introduce this and so we'll come back at
1 30 and then after we finish with this
uh we'll go into executive session so uh
represent getting thanks for hanging in
for two or three more minutes and
representative petrigno uh welcome to
speak to HR 7. have Mr chair before my
friend from Milford begins uh could I
ask a housekeeping question of the chair
sure Mr chair will be Saturday at nine
o'clock and this committee really has
worked hard and well on the leadership
um I noticed at noon time the
temperature in Concord was seven above
with a wind chill of minus 13. and I
know members of the committee of outside
commitments would it be possible to go
with our executive session till four
o'clock recess and then special order
any bills left to next Friday
okay so you're asking about executive
session going possibly until four
o'clock yes sir yes uh I I hear what
you're saying and we you never know how
long a certain you just don't know how
long these things can take some some I
think some of these I think will go
through fairly quickly but to your point
yes uh if if it gets that late we will
uh recess and we'll finish next week
thank you Mr chair sure
okay represent their inceptions social
security and Medicare have made great
strides in reducing poverty in the
United States among seniors and the
disabled as lawmakers in Washington D.C
talk about entitlement reform in other
words cutting these programs it's
important to just take a look at some of
the facts
Social Security by Statute does not
hamper the federal deficit in any way
it is entirely self-funded through
payroll taxations
President Ronald Reagan made this point
very clear
when he said social security has nothing
to do with the deficit Social Security
is totally funded by the payroll tax
living on employers and employees social
security has nothing to do with
balancing a budget or an erasing or
growing the deficit
now in order to fix Social Security
without cutting benefits we can raise
the cap on taxable income presently if
you make a million dollars a year you
only pay social security taxes on the
first 147 thousand dollars
due to increasing income inequality a
historically low number of Americans 83
percent uh paying Social Security taxes
if we ask the wealthy to pay their fair
share we can make the program solvent
so raising the cap secures the trust
fund
this resolution will affirm the New
Hampshire House's commitment to
supporting Social Security and Medicare
and that concludes my testimony thank
you very much
thank you representative
and other will you take questions are as
best I can are there any questions at
this time before I go to represent
infinity I do want to point out as I
said earlier
um I plan to recess this hearing and
come back to it at 1 30. we'll continue
with questions and if there's anyone who
comes in at that time that wants to
speak to this measure at 1 30 we will
give them that time if and if there
isn't anyone then we'll go into exact
session from there so that's how we will
handle that and representative Finney go
ahead
uh thank you
um I am seeing a report here that the
unfunded uh uh that's liabilities for
these programs as of 2021 is 29.9
trillion dollars
how do you how do you see us you know
gaining solvency when when that's it's
like 128
um percent of our GDP it's like it's how
do we sustain that it's you know it just
seems impossible
well I guess some would say that it
seems impossible but as I had mentioned
in the testimony that if more
individuals uh pay their fair share and
we raise that cap that might be one way
to to close to close that Gap and deal
with that uh problem the bottom line is
we don't want to uh leave our seniors
and disabled individuals without a
safety net I can speak to personal
experiences I can just think back to my
own parents and how Social Security was
a benefit for them and and of course
many of us are on Medicare and on social
security so this is something that is
not an entitlement it is something that
we actually pay for and it has nothing
to do with the budget or the deficit so
I do believe that this is something that
we can manage if we take if we take it
seriously
other questions
okay we have some pictures thank you for
your pink card and so I'm not going to
adjourn this hearing I'm going to recess
it as I said at 1 30 we will come back
and if any of the members or if anyone
else wants to speak to HR 7 they'll have
that opportunity at 1 30.
and if once we finish that uh if there
is anyone who wants to speak on the
record uh on on the recording on HR 7
we'll have that opportunity and right
after that we'll go right into executive
session and as I said the Reps of
Representative shortliff we will go
until four at which time we will recess
but perhaps we'll finish before by that
time I think some of these will go
fairly quickly we will see so at this at
this time we'll recess until before I
hit the gavel uh I'd like the folks on
the Republican side to give give us
three or four minutes before you head
out we'll very quick caucus as soon as I
adjourn or recess this hearing thank you
all right folks I'm going to turn the
microphone off uh and I'm going to speak
up and I I know we want to get
okay this is just for the members uh
housekeeping uh I have a message here
from the speaker uh
authorizing legislators who have parked
at store Street to move the uh your
vehicle closer to the to this hearing
building for as of temperature drops
does anybody need to or if because if
you want to do that you need to do it
right now
and I know uh
the question is is that because of an
impending crash of store Street Garage
uh I think it's weather related not
structural
Mike is from Colebrook and and uh you're
you're parked you're from coleburg
anyway so you're good
okay
okay folks it is uh 1 30 it's just after
1 30. uh I'm gonna reopen the uh
recessed hearing on hr7 we had that bill
introduced uh representative if I said
his name correctly
um
did introduce it he's still in the house
thank you for sticking around
representative so if there are any any
further before I open it up to questions
is there anything you would like to add
to the introduction you've already made
of this measure
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee the only point that I'd like
to make is that this is merely a
resolution of firming that the New
Hampshire House of Representatives
supports Social Security and Medicare
it's not really for us to decide how
Congress is going to rectify the problem
it merely is a statement that we believe
that Social Security and Medicare is an
important safety net that millions of
Americans depend on and nothing more so
any questions as to how we resolve the
problem well that really is a matter for
Congress and not this committee
okay questions for US Representative
petrigno on the resolution
and representative Kerry
so why do you feel this resolution is
needed and what impact do you think it
will have
well I think there's a matter of um
philosophical differences
um regarding uh the nature and necessity
of Social Security and Medicare and
there are those of us who believe that
it is a very important safety net and we
do fear that there are others who would
like to see it completely eliminated and
that is the concern we do not want to
see it eliminated we want to see it to
continue and so it really is a matter of
political discussion and hopefully the
New Hampshire House of Representatives
will see fit uh to just affirm the fact
that millions of Americans do indeed
rely on this it's something that we pay
for through payroll deductions we'd like
to see it continued and strengthened and
again it's just an affirmation of our
position as uh representatives of the
people
further questions
okay saying none thank you
representative petrigno I appreciate
your time is there anyone who wants to
submit a pink slip or pink card to speak
to HR 7 before we adjourn that hearing
okay seeing none at this time we will
adjourn the hearing on HR 7 we will have
a executive session today and next week
uh as well and we should finish our
business in this committee next week uh
between the executive session today the
hearings we had today and then exact
next week now up front I'll
share that the ranking member and myself
uh
given the the weather and the
deteriorating
uh or the lowering temperatures we will
um plan to go until if we need to until
four o'clock 1600 hours
you never know how long what type of uh
uh comments and discussion will
accompany any of these measures just
don't know so we may finish before four
if we do not finish before for whatever
is unfinished or whatever we recess we
will uh take up next Friday at beginning
at 10 o'clock right now there are five
measures scheduled for that time so
that's where things stand
so given that let's get right to it uh
the first Yeah question yes uh Mr
chairman two quick things before we
begin uh first of my Democratic
colleagues on the committee thinking
back to my early years especially I
knewa members whenever we'd be an
executive session I would never make a
motion one way or the other because I
didn't want to write the blur up the
committee report and uh
it's like going to confession but anyway
if any of our members want to make a
motion I'll be glad to stay and help you
with the blurb if that's an issue and
the other one thing I want to say Mr
chairman is uh
thank Christina or a Dyer our wonderful
researcher for being one half of a
wonderful duet to this uh national
anthem around session yesterday it was
absolutely beautiful thank you for that
thank you Mr chairman
yes thank you uh Mr ranking member and
uh yes it was wonderful to see our
researcher singing The Anthem
um and yes as far as blurbs go I've been
on other committees and typically the
chair will uh insist that the the
committee reports AKA blurbs uh be
turned in before the member is allowed
to leave this being a Friday uh whoever
ends up doing the blurbs slash committee
reports uh if I could get them Monday
electronically we'll make that work
uh anything else
before we commence
okay let's get right into it then the
first measure on our list to exact is
hb229 which doesn't have a fiscal note
uh relative to requiring an official
declaration of war for the activation of
the New Hampshire National Guard and I'm
looking to uh
a uh
a a young veteran uh
to make a motion on on that or actually
uh I'm going to look to uh represent
London are you prepared to make a motion
yes sir uh I'd like to retain this bill
and work on getting a better language
involved
the motion is to retain and to continue
to work on aspects of it is there a
second I'll second that
motion by representative Lundgren to
retain motion or seconded by
representative pimonte uh representative
Lundgren would you like to speak to your
motion
I already did
thank you okay so the intent of the
motion is to retain and uh
which gives us the option to continue to
work on it through the year and would
anyone else like to speak to the motion
representative Charlotte
thank you Mr Jim and uh I have mixed
emotions about this bill but I think to
retain it and look at it to see if
there's something that can be done uh is
it the good interest of all of us and I
uh and I'm going to support it
thank you representative uh
representative your red light is on did
you wish to okay
uh representative Kerry you
before I asked for a vote are you we
have some different names here I would
just like to check to make sure my
different names because I may not know
all of you although I know the person to
my left here but
um Aiden
ah there you go okay you're here Wayne
McDonald yes yes okay Jennifer Morton
okay uh Marjorie Smith and Jessica
LaMontagne okay all right cool and we've
just I just have to replace you in the
um
just replacing you on my list is
the alternative member
okay I think
I'm almost there let's go get Jessica on
here
well the clerk is confirming the role is
there anyone else you would like to
speak to this measure or this motion uh
representative Banyan
it's a co-sponsor of the bill I'd like
to make a different motion to ought to
pass but we can work on the bill if need
be
understand that you're the uh one of the
sponsors and we do have a motion that
has been made to retain understand that
uh understandably you would like to see
an OTP motion we we already have a
retained motion
that we will vote on uh representative
uh Gagney may I ask a question of uh
representative Manion go ahead
uh representative I know you're one of
sponsor to this but you're are you
leaning to vote to retain this bill or
vote against it I'm going to vote
against thank you
anyone else uh wish to speak to the
measure or the motion
when representative Kerry our clerk is
ready
then uh
we will start in uh the first one the
first name will be the vice chair is
that correct we have okay
uh so representative Rollins yes
okay representative Lundgren
yes
uh oh we don't have Phyllis
um Aidan
anchorberg
anchorberg okay yes
okay McDonald's representative
McDonald's yes
uh representative gagne
no
representative pimonte
yes
representative Finney no
representative Manion no representative
shirtleff yes representative massmilla
yeah
representative or myself yes
representative Morton
yes
representative toll is not here uh Smith
and representative Lamonte
yes you know and representative sieber
yes did I miss anybody yeah the chair
the chair oh well in the chair and and I
missed somebody else over here too
brookson roulette I don't have you on my
list okay so who are you replacing
catch a tourists okay all right let me
see
here we go and tell it tell it tell me
your name again please
Mike and spell your last name for me
o-u-e-l-l-e-t okay all right and uh your
position yes yes okay
and is there some of the else I'm
missing here O'Neill yes
oh I see what we did here
I think you still missed the chair yeah
I still am missing the chair
but so Jessica who are you replacing do
you know
foreign
okay all right so the
paperwork I got from the office has you
replacing okay Lloyd all right okay okay
got it
and O'Neill is actually here
yes
got it all the substitutions there we go
now the chair
yes yes
okay let me just review since we have a
lot of substitutions
I've got uh chair moffa there's a yes uh
representative Rollins yes Lundgren yes
oulette yes
ankenberg I'll get this eventually yes
McDonald yes yes uh gagni no pimonte yes
uh Finney is no Manion is no shirt lift
is yes massmawa is yes
nobody replaced um Boris
uh I think that there is no replacement
no replacement okay Carrie is yes Morton
is yes
uh nobody replaced toll
Smith is yes
LaMontagne is
yes and O'Neill is yes
and Siebert is yes is that correct okay
in the chair oh I got yeah yeah one two
three four five two six
eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
fourteen fifteen fifteen and three is
that right and three does that sound
correct okay 18 people
so the motion to retain passes by a 15-3
vote uh Mr Vice chair
um I do want to point out representative
Manion
um does not have a uh he is really a
member of the he's not a sub he and that
that does make a little bit of
difference and Christine I don't I
somewhere his his uh nameplate
is uh you know we're fine for now but uh
hopefully we'll find it for next week
okay the next measure on the docket is
HB 269 relative to limiting The
Authority of New Hampshire delegates to
policy making conventions
I'm gonna
I
have been informed that there may be an
amendment pending
um representative Finney has anything
come to you yet on that or not
suppose uh hard copies of this like any
minute now okay we'll pass by that for
now in case uh there is an amendment
it's in our email but we need we need
hard copies
and we'll get if we don't get to it by
four o'clock we will um have next week
to finish this off so we will come back
to HB 269 uh which brings us now to hcr3
uh relative to affirming States power
over the Federal Constitution
Mr ranking remember do you have uh
someone from from over there that might
want to make a motion on that one
uh we're all free Spirits Mr chairman so
you could ask the whole group uh is
there any Democrat that wants to make a
motion on this uh
if there is I'll pass it around to the
chair
it has to be a uh excuse me Mr chair
does it has to be a regular it can't be
it's something a substitute correct
rules yeah
uh so looking for a motion on uh hcr3
and um and thank you for it's good to
know we have free Spirits so absolutely
Spirits anyway and uh representative
language I'm going to look to you again
uh would you have a motion uh that you
might want to make on this measure
hdr3 I
second
put a bipartisan ship
so you have a motion to itl in expedient
to legislate made by representative
Lundgren seconded by representative
shurtleff
representative Lundgren would you care
to speak to your motion
no
representative shurliff is the secondary
would you care to speak to the to your
to the motion here uh representative
language already made my comment for me
thank you Mr chair well I'll speak
briefly uh I think it's a slippery slope
when a state will try to use syrup a
federal uh uh the Federal Constitution
and I think uh the 20th Amendment given
women the right to vote it was only
ratified by one vote in Kentucky uh that
the state could say no to that or civil
rights or anything else that we've done
uh for the betterment of the people that
live in our country and I uh I don't
think we want to go to one state being
able to nullify the work of the entire
country
thank you representative shurliff uh
anyone else want to speak to the motion
representative Shirley have mentioned
the 20th Amendment giving women the
right to vote I think it might have been
the 19th for the record uh we want to
make sure that uh that we have that
right uh
was it the 19th Amendment
okay
the rank member was testing me and and
uh yes we all should know is the 19th
amendment that gave women the right to
vote
anything else on the motion to itl
seeing saying nothing I would ask the
clerk to read the role on the motion to
itl
Rollins
yes mundgren
yes
inkerberg yes
McDonald's yes yagni yes pimonte
yes
Vinnie yes
Manion yes shirt lip yes Miss vanilla
yes
okay
um Carrie no yes yes uh Morton yes
Smith yes Lamontagne
yes O'Neill
and Siebert
okay
so that that's a unanimous 18. and the
chair oh sorry
uh yes
I I was just you know looking into the
future
you were also testing me as as was
uh representative
yes I've got to stick you in here you
weren't on the original list okay who
let his replacing last time it was uh
is he oh gosh he oh cast of force yeah
yes yeah
Mike
okay
okay and he's a yes correct
so do I understand it's unanimous yes
and what's the count one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten eleven
twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen sixteen
Seventeen eighteen yeah
okay we have eighteen to zero uh voting
for the motion to
itl
would move consent
yes uh with with unless there's some
objection there is no FN to that so uh
without objection Madam chair will
put that on the consent calendar
thank you representative gagne
okay that brings us to uh hcr4 this is
the uh the measure of the resolution
urging Congress to propose a
constitutional amendment to establish
Congressional term limits
uh representative Lundgren look your way
again do you have a motion for us
I'm thinking back to early discussion
today which had to do with retain
um I have it written on the wrong one
I'm sorry so the motion is to retain is
is there a second to the motion to
retain hcr4
thank you representative shurtleff
seconds the motion to
uh retain hcr4 uh representative
Lundgren or representative shurtleff uh
would you represent care to speak to the
motion
president thank you Mr chairman
um I believe when Representatives God
introduced this bill he talked a lot
about the amount of money in uh
Congressional politics and um
which was one of their motivations for
him to file this and so I I think
there's some real thoughts about this
idea of the money that's going into our
national Congressional elections and so
I would support the uh through tension
thank you representative sherliff would
anyone else would anyone else like to
speak to the motion
representative Finney
um I think that we should go back to the
original uh OTP because we've
I've already talked about this in uh
concurring bills with Article 5 issues
that it's all encompassing for for
specific issues I don't think that we
need to retain the bill I think that we
know what the bill does and we that we
need to pass it
thank you representative the motion is
to retain uh representative Smith
thank you very much Mr chair
um aside from the fact that I'm
fascinated to think that a body that
operates without term limits that would
be the New Hampshire House of
Representatives would determine for
another legislative body that there
should be term limits
I find that intriguing
um and not to say wrong just something
worthy of note
um I uh I personally am
very concerned about the money that I
believe is inappropriate and corrupting
that goes into all elections State and
National and would like to see that
change I have no reason to believe that
term limits would make the change their
other direct steps that would have to be
taken to make that change so that we no
longer are victims of those people who
make major contributions to political
Activity thank you
would anyone else like to speak yes
representative massamila
wait where we do have a Convention of
states that we need to have things in
place before that happens that is very
definitive as to what the objective is
for that convention thank you
thank you represent Master Miller would
any would anyone else like to speak to
the motion
I will say to representative Master
Miller's point that this is uh it's
neither an OTP or an ilt it's it is a
motion to retain
and not knowing at this time what will
happen with uh the hdr1 measure or the
convention of the states we can uh
because if this passes it will be
retained and is something that we can
bring back
um within the year
to your point so this still could be
used in that fashion except if the
retain measure passes it wouldn't be
able to be used immediately for that
purpose
any other comments questions
seeing none uh Madam clerk if you would
read the role for the retain motion on
hcr4
okay Rollins yes
Lundgren
yes roulette
yes
engenburg yes
McDonald's yes gagne
no
Humanity
yes
Vinnie no
Manion no shirtless yes
Miller
uh let's see Carrie yes
Morton
yes
Marjorie Smith yes okay and Lamontagne
O'Neill
and Siebert
so we've got one two on the chair
yes
one two seven eight nine ten eleven
twelve thirteen fourteen
and four
so the count is 14 in favor of the
motion it retained four against
so I will work on a majority Report with
representative Lundgren will would uh
would someone care to make a Minority
Report
um
on this on this retainer although
they're they're
procedurally uh representative shirtle
if you may know this on a retain measure
typically are there two or more if if
the vote is split
okay that thing that thank you Christine
that clears up my question so on a
retained measure there's no need for
either a majority or Minority Report
well it's retained thank you that
answers that okay
uh the next measure is uh yeah very high
profile measure this is the one that we
had the hearing on a week ago in Repsol
that was had a a very large number of
people attend and testify this is uh the
resolution applying for a Convention of
the states under Article 5 of The
Constitution of the United States HCR
one
um representative Finney do you have a
motion on this measure I do I move that
uh we ought to pass hcr1 and I'll speak
to my motion okay do we have a second
representative massimilla seconds uh
representative Finney's
OTP motion on HCR one represent Finney
would you care to speak to your motion I
would uh thank you um well you know from
all the information that we've heard in
the last couple weeks about what an
article 5 convention actually does and
what it does not do I think we can
safely assume that all the safeguards in
place the amount of states that would
have to apply and then have to ratify an
amendment that all of the myths and the
you know the the the the mongering on
fear on what a convention what or
wouldn't do is is false I think that um
we're at the point politically and
socially and culturally where we need to
actually have you know systemic changes
in in the way that our that our federal
government functions and the founders
Incorporated that in our constitution
it's the safest you know most
non-violent way to uh to do this and we
need to rein back the power of congress
and uh flip the power Dynamic back to
the States over the federal government
so that we can assert our sovereignty
and you know and protect our future I
think it's the best way to do it this
committee has a history of not passing
these bills um based on uh uh you know
the information from the other side that
would say that this this would uh
harm our process or or our functionality
and I just I just don't see how that's
possible
um all the information that we got uh
from the experts
overwhelmingly states that this is the
best way to achieve what we're trying to
do as a country and uh it's got to start
somewhere so it should start with us
thank you representative representative
Massa Miller who made the second would
you care to speak to to the to the
measure
the only thing
I is
that the forefathers were wise enough to
realize that when men become it come
into power and are authoritative that
sometimes that power can be misused and
then what are we left with we're left
with the people trying to make a
decision as to what to do and I think
they were wise enough to put that as an
article
and I think that we should respect that
and then the other thing I read a quote
the other day that I think is applicable
it says fear and faith both demand that
you believe in something that you cannot
see and you make the choice and I think
faith is what's needed here as far as
um yes maybe it's never been done before
though some people say yes it has but
that it was put into the Constitution I
think is important so thank you
thank you representative massanola uh
representative
thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman there
are times that I wish I had the
eloquence of my friend from Durham
representative Smith and this is one of
those times uh
I'm opposed to the bill and we'll be
voting no I thank the sponsors for
bringing it in and the information they
gave us all in good faith uh but in my
heart of hearts I just cannot support a
constitutional convention I still have
concerns about other issues being
brought up and for that reason I'll be
voting no thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative
uh representative Finney you've already
spoken to your motion before I go back
to you uh
someone who has yet to speak on the
motion is there anyone else who would
like to do so
I'll have a comment myself uh but go
ahead representative Finney to to
clarify what we're voting on is not a
constitutional convention it's an
article 5 convention there are two
you know completely separate things the
Constitutional Convention is to create a
new Constitution Article 5 is just to
propose amendments which is what our
right is to do we
you know
representative Smith
thank you first of all um Mr chair
ordinarily I believe that the gentleman
from Concord is very accurate in what he
says but he really was I think saying
something not quite accurate to indicate
that he is not the most eloquent person
in the room I think he is
um on another Point
um I um it's been a long time since I
have been in the classroom as a student
but not a long time since I've studied
the Constitution and and lots of
material relating to it perhaps I'm
wrong but I remember very clearly that
when the Articles of Confederation were
not working the way the people wanted
them to work
um they asked for an opportunity to
amend the Articles of Confederation and
what they did
was to eventually end up creating
the Constitution to which all of us in
this room have
tended to varying degrees
to pledge our Allegiance I
do not believe that the country
um
is perfect I don't believe that the
constitution is perfect but for any for
for several hundred years we have limped
along trying to make it better and
better
and I would hope that we would not do
anything that might
um
interfere with that constancy as we have
worked together to form a more perfect
union so I um
I I plan to vote against the um the
motion thank you
thank you representative uh reps of
gagne
thank you Mr chairman
you know I'm just plain bread
high school graduate
I'm not a lawyer doctor or anything I
don't have any you know what
the things that I did I did with my
fists I was a martial arts instructor
back in the day
now
this is my eighth term
all the previous terms I voted no to an
article five
I wasn't that informed this time out
because I'm on this committee
something came out about this thick
and believe it or not this High School
guy read the whole thing
and I found out that you know the people
have got to have a voice in what goes on
in our government because it's for us
not for them it's for us so I am going
to be wholeheartedly voting for this
article 5 convention
thank you representative
anyone else
representative manian
along those same lines uh I've always
been a proponent of article five as a
mechanism to
keep the federal government in check
it's been the sole body to propose and
have amendments passed and the states
have that power it was put there for a
reason because there are things that
Congress itself will not propose to fix
itself so it must be up to the states to
do so and that's what this is for
thank you representative
anyone else
I have a couple thoughts
uh I am like representative gagne in
that uh this is not a measure I
supported in the past uh it came to this
committee last term and uh
I want to say was on consent I I there
was uh not much energy or interest in it
uh last term
but that was last term and I I must say
that
like representative gagne
um
I try to honor the people who came and
testified of which we had many many many
more this term than last term
and I did some reading as as
representative gagne did and I listened
and again the reason that we were in
reps Hall last week was because of the
uh the volume the the great number of
people who wanted to weigh in on on this
measure
uh one of the things that I've kind of
uh concluded is that a lot of the
opposition to the to this measure is
largely fear driven which is not unusual
uh almost any measure that we we uh deal
with the opponents of it will try to you
know Stoke fears for one of a better
term because they think that it's not
the best way to go
uh but again if you go back to the
Federalist Papers or the founders
there's a reason that they had this they
put this mechanism in place they put
this uh this option this mechanism in
place as a as a as an option for
uh us to utilize
um if necessary earlier today I found it
very interesting in a hearing of a
different Bill uh that had to do with uh
an amendment to the Constitution uh I
believe it was the 21st Amendment which
repealed prohibition that came up this
morning and it was pointed out that the
movement there was an article 5 movement
of four
uh the prohibition measure and because
of that article 5 movement the
traditional uh way of amending the
Constitution came about we got article
21 which perhaps would not have happened
the same way if at all had it not been
for the the chance for a uh an article 5
convention so I'm going to stop there
other than you can see where I'm going
with this I I'm going to vote for this
measure this time around and then
another point I want to make is
that I've learned that in the past this
committee is like I said it came up last
term but another term that came up and
it came out of this committee
unanimously in favor of an article 5
convention and procedurally it did not
get to the Senate so there's some
interesting history on both sides uh for
this measure in the past so and the
final thing I I want to say is that
committees have a lot of power
um and if something comes out of
committee uh
one way or the other it matters usually
a lot on the house floor
and I would like to see the the
this measure move forward so
other folks can give it full
consideration which I think is more
likely to happen if it comes out of this
committee uh with a favorable
recommendation rather than rather than
to kill it so those are my thoughts on
it does anyone else have anything that
they would like to speak yes
representative O'Neill
resonated with me which is when I took a
hard look at why my initial reaction to
this was no I realized it was fear
um and I you know as I look
introspectively what I fear more is
nothing changing
um and this is the mechanism we have to
try to do that
so I'll be voting yes
thank you representative
anyone else
reps of Kerry
as you know I like to follow the money
because I believe everything in life
goes back to that
we had a speaker who was flown in to
speak to us I did look up their 990s
65.19 million dollars in Revenue this
non-profit made
it defines itself as a legal Ministry
Conservative Christian curtailing rights
for lgbtq expanding Christian practices
in Public Schools and Government and
outlawing abortion that Disturbed me
that Disturbed me because this was a
keynote speaker and this is what this
individual represented
and so while initially
I had
no concerns with an article 5 convention
I began to be concerned because
this is the keynote speaker so then I
pulled the 990s of the organization I
believe
that has been speaking to us more
directly mark meckler would be the head
of that organization and I looked up how
much he and his wife were making running
this organization and as someone with a
degree in non-profit management I'm a
little Disturbed at how much money these
people make advocating
for this sort of thing so I'm troubled
by following the money because
everything in life every action we take
goes back to who pulls the strings and
who has the money
so this is my concern and this is what I
have not settled in my mind
thank you representative
anyone else
seeing no hands at this time then Madam
clerk if you would call the roll on the
motion on hcr1 which is a motion to OTP
ought to pass
okay representative Rollins yes
representative Lundgren yes
roulette
yes
anarkenberg yes
McDonald's yes
Cagney
yes pimonte
yes
oh yes
Manion yes shirtless
massilla
myself Carrie
I am I I know I'm conflicted Larry I'm
conflicted
I have to you you have to pick one of
the other uh representative I'm flipping
a coin right now
I think I think I'm going to say no
because I can't decide uh Morton no no
Smith
no
lamenting
yes
O'Neill
yeah
seabird no
okay ten to three four cheer
the chair votes yes
13 yep 13 yeses and five no's
13 to 5 the measure uh
OTP passes uh
aggressive
Finney you will
communicate with me on a majority report
I'll get that to you at on Sunday and on
the other side with someone who voted no
care to uh make the case against the OTP
see this last last call for someone to
make a Minority Report or a committee
report against the OTP measure
see
seeing none we're essentially you said
no you know
okay uh so we'll have one report uh that
representative Finney will draft up and
uh and thank you for that
okay moving right along uh
hr8 that's
urging Congress to enact legislation
regulating and banning certain
semi-automatic assault weapons in large
capacity ammunition feeding devices
representative man you indicated a
desire to make a motion motion Ito
do I have a second for that motion
representative Finney seconds the motion
um
representative Manny would you care to
speak to emotion uh yes so
uh Firearms have a strong uh history in
this country and during the testimony
there was many things that came up uh
one of which is like the Riots of 2020
uh there was many instances where so the
there's carve outs in this bill that
allow law enforcement to maintain arms
as well so there's this whole thing this
theory that the uh only people that
should be allowed to carry firearms
especially those are the law enforcement
uh during the summer of 2020 several
businesses across this entire country
called out to 9-1-1 to law enforcement
agencies they said uh they're you know
there's people outside there's lots of
people outside what do I do they said
the police are preoccupied you're on
your own this entire
that entire argument in and of itself I
think is open and shut but then there
was another woman who actually brought
up a really good point because the
actual purpose of this is for personal
defense against all enemies for your
person your home your your country
because one of the uh testifiers brought
up
Ukraine which I thought was really
important because the people of Ukraine
were disarmed by their country decades
back
and during the invasion they are
scrambling now to train up people who
don't have the culture they don't have
the training they don't have firearms
they're readily available that they use
every day and now they have to scramble
to Sprint these people to be ready
to fight a war that they're not ready
for that here there's hobbyists there's
individuals like that go out on weekends
and they train with arms like this
country could never be invaded in such a
way that like Ukraine is we it is not
possible there's no force on this planet
like the civilian populace here is
stronger than a lot of armies on this
entire planet the United States could
never be invaded in such a way
so that's why I vote itl Mr chairman
would be possible would the member yield
to a question yes yes go ahead thank you
Mr chairman thank you I thank the member
you talk about Ukraine being disarm
decades ago you of course realize that
was the Russians that disarmed them it's
still bad and it's now invading that
country oh yeah it's so bad it
yeah I mean But the irony is
well I don't even mention the irony
because it's pretty obvious but I thank
the member for taking my yeah absolutely
it's the who who did it is to me it's
it's a moot point because one government
or another government coming in and
saying you can't own arms it's in the
history of like more than just Ukraine
if you look at like the Soviet Union you
look at China like these areas they're
they were disarmed before Mass genocide
it's step one to genocide is disarm the
populace
and in an exact session I encourage
people to do what just happened if you
want a clarification want to make a
point uh please ask to do what
representative Sherlock just did and
asked directly uh Finney you seconded
the motion do you have do you want to
speak to your second
I didn't know I could
um
I think it's it's pretty clear that the
Second Amendment isn't about hunting we
all know that it's about uh the the idea
of individual sovereignty protecting
ourselves against tyranny and I know
that sounds like a lofty thing that you
probably hear and it's a political you
know term that gets thrown around a lot
but it's a serious thing and you know
and especially here in
um in this state where where we believe
in our own individual power as a state
and and then and as an individual body
it's important that we maintain the
right to defend ourselves in our
property and other people and I will say
um anecdotally that during that that
time there were people that were that
had had come up to Manchester to do the
exact same thing was was to loot and
riot
and uh
I I took it upon myself and a couple of
my friends to go there with arms to
defend the businesses but also to defend
the people's right to protest
and if we don't
have that right in this country with
arms to make the people that have power
over us
uh you know second guess what their next
move would be
look we're we're talking about what
these guns do and don't do
these these guns have the same
functionality no matter what they look
like and I think a lot of what people
are afraid of is how they look but like
you know terms you know military style
is is is funny to me because those of us
who have been in the military we all
know
that you know that it's the same
function as what you get in a civilian
gun
and if if we're trying to say as a state
to urge Congress to ban these things
um I think it's an ignorance on our part
that there's a lot of people who came to
this committee and didn't even know what
their terms meant they don't know what
high capacity means that's a buzzword
that means doesn't mean anything it's
not how it works
um so if people are are going to come
here and and you know tell us to tell
Congress to ban things they should
probably know what they're talking about
first we should know what we're talking
about if we're trying to say to people
that you don't have the right to own
something because of X Y and Z it's not
our role as a government to do that it's
it's it's antithetical to what we signed
up to defend we sworn all to the
Constitution and enacting
a bill or
you know whatever you know and you know
somebody
um excuse me an HR or an HCR is you know
and I was effectively saying that we
don't believe in the oath that we swore
to I think that's wrong and I I you know
I think it's unethical and immoral we
don't have the right to ban anything
uh representative uh Rollins has a hand
up and then representative Smith did
thank you Mr chairman uh I remember back
when I was in high school uh that's when
the first thing I was handgun control
came out and then I watched the sales of
handguns explode a few years after that
uh I got married I went to work for
Sturm Ruger firearms incorporation for
27 years
and our sales depended on who was
president
when there was a Democratic president
and they were pushing for gun control
the sales went through the roof the
overtime was all you wanted
when a republican came in control
then the sales dropped to nothing okay
they dropped flat I remember
um
at one point when they when the um many
14s that we made semi-automatic rifles
it was so dead that we had like 50 60
000 in stock and we couldn't sell them
then another president came along
Democratic president came along and said
I'm banning all semi-automatic weapons
it only took a month to two months to be
able to box those guns up into sell
those guns and to put them on the market
the line had been dead they were trying
to gear it up they couldn't even gear it
up in time before the weapons were gone
and it goes back and forth from one
president to the next if people are
comfortable that they know that guns are
going to be safe then they'll spend
money on other things when they're
worried that they'll never be able to
get another one that's where they buy in
Mass so gun control often times just me
just magnifies the sale of of all
firearms if we would just let people
live we wouldn't and never started with
gun control in the first place you would
not see the mass gun ownership in
manufacturing that we have in this
country at this time that's all I got to
say
thank you representative Rollins
representative Smith
thank you very much first of all I'd
like to say how delighted I am as a
Democrat that apparently we're so good
for the economy I think that's that's
great I'm pleased to hear that
um but I could could I ask
representative Finney a question sure
um
if I don't want to misquote you and so
tell me if I'm wrong but I think I heard
you say that you do not believe that we
as a legislature should ban anything is
that what you said I I was I was trying
to to refer to the to the Banning of
firearms I apologize for that not
clarification thank you for that
clarification
thank you representative Smith
representative shortlist
thank you Mr chairman there's been a lot
of discussion about this bill Banning uh
guns that's not what this resolution
does it bans assault weapons in a band's
large capacity uh magazines
Mr chairman I carried a gun for three
years in the military one year of that
in combat I carried a gun as a Concord
police officer for five years and went
to school with Larry the Old State
Police Academy I carried a gun for 26
years the United States Marshal I've
been a licensed tunnel in New Hampshire
since I've been 16 going to the NRA say
on a safety program out at the old
Pioneer Sportsman's Club
I bet
I own weapons shot long guns and shot in
handguns I'm not anti-gun but I am sick
and tired to see the 18 or 19 year old
kid walking into a school with a
semi-automatic weapon in a high-capacity
magazine and children being slotted
we're seeing too much of that it's
coming now on a daily basis in this
country there's no need for any
Sportsman a true Sportsman to have an
assault weapon or a high capacity of 50
uh a magazine clip for a firearm it's
beyond the pail and I'm going to support
this I'm going to vote against the
motion and I uh I urge my colleagues to
do the same thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative shurliff
of their hands other comments uh
represent O'Neill
thank you um first I want to Echo uh
what representative shurtlove said as
well we have a problem in this country
um especially with school shootings I
have school-aged children they are
trained at this point to cower in a
corner due to an emergency which is as
apparent to hear them describe that
process nothing short of horrifying and
I also just want to point out
um you know as you you know my
colleagues were referencing some
situations happening within our state of
New Hampshire and involving guns I want
to remind everyone that we as New
Hampshire residents lost a New Hampshire
child last May a little boy from
Portsmouth my son's friend my husband
coached him due to someone with mental
health issues and and a history of drug
abuse with a house full of ammunition
standing on the side of the road firing
at every car that drove by eight years
old he was killed
um so I am I am not one to be in support
of
um being totally against guns but there
there has to be something done these
weapons I just don't feel are necessary
and we have to do do something
thank you representative O'Neill
representative mastermilla
thank you
um I think when the forefathers put the
Second Amendment in not in their Wildest
Dreams could they have ever imagined the
type of Weaponry we have today
and if they did I'm sure that they would
relegate it to the militia
so therefore I can't support the OTP
thank you representative
representative Cheryl if you might want
to hit your light there
other
hands comments
seeing none uh representative Seibert
yeah I would like to say that I'm not in
support of this amendment I think things
that were brought up about like the
Revolutionary War and things like that
is when you know people arm themselves
they were not these types of weapons so
I concur
well no it says representative you
should you need to ask if the
representative would like to take a
question before you for you before you I
hate to say fire before you before you
shoot off a question
um but but do you represent will you
take a question for something would you
believe that the Second Amendment says
arms not what kind of arms but it says
arms and it specifically says arms
because they understood that that
technology would change over time that
the technology has changed but again
it's people who use terms incorrectly
who don't know what these terms mean
that are saying that these things are
happening and
uh the amount of people who die from gun
deaths is actually under a hundred
thousand a year and yet obesity kills a
hundred thousand people a year and yet
we don't ban you know all the fast food
places that are on every corner that are
killing people every year but so this is
a highly charged topic uh because it's
become a you know a political football
but we have to to you know to examine it
as a policy issue that the policy is
that that the government cannot ban
something that is already protected in
the Constitution
is
the bottom line may ask the member a
question will you take a question I'll
take one more question and I'm done
talking no my only question is you told
us about the Second Amendment and if
that was what's before us right now I
totally agree the Second Amendment is
very open and I think this uh
misunderstandings but we aren't talking
about the Second Amendment we're talking
about the resolution before us now to
ban assault weapons and large capacity
magazines that's what's before this
committee not the Second Amendment but
if we do that I do believe right but if
we do that it's in direct
violation of our oath every amendment to
the Constitution is what we swore to
protect not and we don't get to pick and
choose
other questions comments
okay I have a request to move the vote
which we will do at this time so I would
ask Madam clerk to call the role on the
itl motion on hr8
urging Congress to enact legislation
regulating and banning certain
semi-automatic assault weapons in large
capacity ammunition feeding devices
yes
roulette
yes okay just shout out to your own name
when I look at the directions
McDonald's yes the agony yes pimonte
yes
Vinnie yes Manion yes shirtless no
massmilla no
Carrie no
uh Morton no
Smith no Lamontagne
O'Neill no
and Siebert
okay
one two three four five six and chair
the chair will vote Yes
so it looks like eight and Ninth
Mr chairman oh no I'll do a minute
already blurb on this okay okay let's
oh I'm sorry let him announce the uh the
numbers
foreign
did you make the motion that was you I
believe represent Manion uh you'll work
on a report committee report
representative shirtle if you indicated
you would as well
okay we'll be looking for those on on
Monday
okay moving to the next measure which
would be hr9 this calls for the federal
government to enact and quote American
martial plan
unquote to rebuild economically
impoverished communities and strengthen
climate resilience infrastructure
represent man you indicated a desire to
make a motion make a motion Ito
motion to itl
and
we need a second for that
I'll second uh was that representative
gagne seconds
so we have Motion in a second to itl hr9
representative Manion would you care to
speak to your motion uh
in the current uh economic climate we
cannot be spending and by that I mean
printing more money at the federal
government to pay for green New Deal
projects
representative gagne would you care to
speak to your second
ditto
becoming succinct here okay uh would
anyone else care to speak on either side
of the uh the motion to itl
representative shurliff as I break my
glasses
um Mr chairman I'll be voting against
the motion uh I think this unmarried and
what this bill proposes the idea of the
Marshall Plan that we know what it did
for Europe after World War II or brought
that back we have impoverished areas of
our country that could use something
like the Marshall Plan to get them back
to work and to improve their lives and
to improve their infrastructure and so
I'll be voting against the motion
thank you representative shirtleff
anyone else yes representative gagne
my old uh police academy buddy
uh
I agree with everything that you're
saying about improving the life and the
infrastructure of this country however
however how can we do that when we have
an open border people are coming in
using up all our resources that could be
used for some of this stuff and until we
close the border
and address those issues then I don't
think this is necessary because we don't
have any money for it
thank you representative gagne
anyone uh representative Smith are you
giving me a signal here
uh please please go ahead
thank you very much
um
could I ask representative Cagney my
distinguished colleague's question
yes
thank you I'm glad you gave it some
consideration you shouldn't just decide
you shouldn't decide just you know
happenstance I was really interested to
hear
what you said about
um
who you believe is using up all of our
resources
um
I
I'm not sure that I I know that your
background I certainly know about mine
and I know about the background of many
many of my colleagues we are a nation of
immigrants
we are if I could finish we are a nation
of immigrants and as I drive around the
state I see place after place please
from that's
p-l-e-a-s from employers asking for
people to come and work for them we have
always thrived in this country by having
people come in and sometimes take jobs
that the rest of us aren't willing to do
and
um I don't see any relationship and
maybe you can help me between this
attempt to say Let's help those people
who need help to achieve the American
dream and your suggestion that the
problem has to do with
illegal immigration
yes in part I totally
agree I I I totally believe that a lot
of our funds are being used up by people
coming in illegally look I'm an
immigrant my parents came from Canada we
were turned away the Border because my
parents held up they waited and their
visas ran out the Visas ran out so we
had to go back to Quebec City
and reapply for our Visas so we could
come in here legally and we got we got
jobs we started working
I was six years old when I came here but
I do I do remember going through the
process of showing the little green card
so if not I am not opposed to Legal
immigration
I am
opposed to people coming in here it's an
invasion
being put on buses being put on planes
living in hotel rooms on the dime of the
taxpayer I have a problem with that and
until that is addressed I don't think
the Marshall Plan would work even if it
was put into place
okay I need I think I need to point out
we're getting into an immigration
discussion here in the the most the uh
measure uh does not mention immigration
uh per se although uh I understand how
how it's being pulled into the
discussion and that's uh and that's
that's okay
um
other hands representative uh Lamontagne
yes I would be in favor of this bill I
think we are woefully unprepared for the
future
uh climate change it is uh
we need to start investing now
and I believe that you know we already
benefited from a domestic version of the
Marshall Plan in the post-war period
when there was a tremendous amount of
federal investment in building our
infrastructure
but that was over 50 years ago
uh and it's all crumbling and needs to
be rebuilt and there's we can't do this
state by state this needs to be a
federal project and we need to start
planning
on a massive scale
and it has nothing to do with immigrants
thank you representative LaMontagne
other hands
representative Siebert
I just wanted to say that um I I
definitely reflect um
one of the statements that just was said
um but yeah I think that you know for
any business owner investor in the room
um you see when you put
something into something as an
investment you get returned back for
that
and usually in a positive way so
thank you representative
anyone else
saying no further hands at this time I
would ask the uh ask Madam clerk to call
the rule on HR 9 with regard to an
American Marshal plan to rebuild
economically impoverished communities
and strengthen climate resilience
infrastructure the motion to the to this
measure is itl
and uh please call call the roll
yes
I forgot my name first thing
that I'm not the only one having a
problem with that one okay McDonald's
yes
gag me yes pimonte
yes Vinnie yes
Manion yes shirtleff
massmella
myself yes
Morton no
Smith
yes oh wait I got confused
the Motions to itl Ito then I'm no okay
you wanted to say uh Lamontagne
O'Neill
and Siebert
in zero and the chair
yes
so we've got seven days
11 11 years yep
yes
represent Manion will communicate on a
committee report and would would anyone
care to do a uh a second report yeah
a Minority Report so to speak
um okay so we we'll have we will have at
least one report uh thank you
representative Manion
no Minority Report uh none at this time
has been
has been asked to be scheduled excuse me
okay uh moving right along
um
two HR 10 supporting statehood for the
District of Columbia
and representative pimani did you
earlier indicate an interest in making a
motion on this uh yes thank you Mr chair
um I make a motion itl HR 10.
motion to itl is there a second
the second from representative Finney
okay representative pimani would you
care would you care to speak to your
motion to itl
IES thank you Mr chair
um a couple of things New Hampshire is
kind of premature
tell Department I mean to District of
Columbia to uh either go to statehood I
I would think it would be basically up
to them to make their own decisions and
doing things like that down there we've
had representative C said that they
should join Maryland I mean you know
I'm sorry uh I think representative C uh
mentioned that they should cooperate uh
I mean join Maryland and uh in in
becoming able to vote in the the
elections and things like that so
it's basically it
thank you representative pimonte uh the
seconder was uh represent Finney do you
want to speak to the second
I concur
representative Smith has her hand up uh
thank you very much could I ask a
question of Representative camonte
thank you very much
um I'm intrigued that your suggestion
that the District of Columbia should
um ask to join
um another state and give up their
independence there have been lots of
concerns that have been expressed in
many Arenas about the fact that New
Hampshire is so small and Vermont is so
small and yet we each have two senators
whereas States like California and Texas
and Florida each also have two senators
so would you think it would be good idea
for New Hampshire and Vermont to become
one state and have only two senators in
order to equal equal that and in which
is basically what you're asking DC and
Maryland to do thank you very much uh no
I was just actually repeating the
statements from from one of the
representatives that testified on
joining and I use that as an example but
basically I resort to my original
statement of having the District of
Columbia
go for their own uh statehood I mean
those are the people that that are that
are there they they should do that if
they want you know
yeah go ahead I think you might know
representative pamandi that the citizens
of the District of Columbia have been
trying for many many years to achieve
statehood they vote on it
um Whenever there is an appropriate
election where they can vote on it they
make they State their claim and they
speak to the representatives of the uh
U.S Congress so they're doing everything
that they can they can't make that
decision by themselves it has to be made
by the country as a whole and that's why
New Hampshire has been asked as every
other state has been asked to recognize
that if they are in this country they
have a right to be represented in the
Congress
well thank I I feel also elections have
consequences okay if they tried harder
to tried hard to do this they should try
harder if they want the statehood
that's just my represent Messer Miller
has a hand up
um I just wanted to support what um
representative Smith said and also I
concurred with my colleague
representative Lundgren and we've had
this before the committee before and we
did have people from DC come and testify
in favor of statehood so thank you
thank you Mr chairman
um I'm going to vote against the motion
I'll be brief I think it's unfair that
when you have a quarter of a million
citizens of the United States
who a vast majority want statehood and
to be represented in in Congress uh
the we should do all we can to support
their Endeavors and their efforts and so
I will be voting against the motion to
itl
and thank you Mr chair
thank you representative shirtleff
you want to ask a question of whom
sorry
I just so just like you know for the
body that's okay like I don't know if we
ever thought about this during the
testimony that that we got for this bill
but like why couldn't they have put this
on the on the ballot for the federal
election has ever been on the ballot
before
I don't know if it's been on the ballot
I'm not sure if we do National
referendum son on uh
on in a federal election
okay
represent Manion
um
I'm pretty
why would she watching with history but
if I remember correctly it was Virginia
and Maryland both donated
the land for the use of DC with the
explicit purpose of it not belonging to
a specific State because they didn't
want one state to have overwhelming
power if those individuals that live in
the residential areas of DC would like
to be part of a state I do like the idea
of returning it to what the state who
which uh donated it
yes I can tell you that originally the
federal district that became known as a
district of Columbia was taking land
from both Maryland and Virginia if you
look at the map uh you'll notice that
all the land in the district is north of
the Potomac so Virginia
uh ended up keeping their what's now
Arlington and Alexandria is part of
Virginia so they pull that out of the
federal district
but the land that came from Maryland is
still is what does now make up District
of Columbia
other questions or comments
representative Smith can I I'm going to
ask permission to ask you a a tough
question if if you'll allow me
oh dear of course I'll allow you Mr
chair I would never say no well we're
here to talk about these things and let
me ask you this
you may or may not know about 90 percent
of the voters in the district vote for
one party approximately 90 percent might
even be higher than 90 percent
um would you look at this differently if
if the 90 percent of the voters voted
for the other party
um Mr chair I think that's a perfectly
legitimate question to ask and I would
say I don't look at it differently I
would still feel the same way because I
feel that every citizen of this country
should have a right to be represented in
in Congress and to show you how
how much to do to document the um
Integrity of my answer I would point out
to you that I have for three years and
one of our colleagues can can testify to
this been the prime sponsor on creating
an independent redistricting commission
here in this state because I do not
think that we should create systems that
favor one party or the other and at the
beginning of this process actually the
incumbent Governor supported my proposal
and then he was asked by the uh uh the
then head of the Republican
redistricting organization not to
support it because he wanted to make
sure that the state of New Hampshire
favored Republicans in redistricting I
believe if the Democrats had been in
charge the Democratic governor would
likely have opposed redistricting
because the Democratic governor would
have wanted to continue to have
favoritism to the Democrats I however
and you asked the question of me believe
as strongly as possible that we should
not be making decisions based on Party
Loyalty and I've demonstrated that and
will my my colleague to the left support
the fact that I've done that
no
will you take a question Russell
McDonald
uh yeah you yeah yes uh representative
Smith is also a substitute oh okay
I did serve on the redistricting
committee with representative Smith and
and she did support an independent
redistricting commission and she also
supported legislation in front of the
election lock committee which I was on
last term to that effect so she is she
is accurate when she's saying thank you
thank you representative Smith for
taking my question I do want to make one
more comment with regard to uh
representative manion's uh question
about the the district
and uh we we actually had a hearing on
this measure in reps Hall before the big
HC HCR one hearing and I remember
and I I spoke I won't say who I spoke to
but I spoke to a very senior veteran
legislator who came up with what I
thought was a a wonderful suggestion he
he what I had which I had never heard
before he suggested just taking the uh
Congressional buildings in the White
House and and the uh Department of
Commerce and creating a federal district
of like a couple square miles where
where the business takes place and
having the residential parts of DC will
revert to Maryland is is what happened
with Virginia
this would mean that Maryland would
probably get at least one more
representative these people would would
then no longer be subject to taxational
representation I never heard of that but
I thought that was I thought it was
brilliant and I'm going to keep keep
that file away but it's not part of this
measure but uh to your point about the
the shape of the district and that type
of thing
anyone else uh care to speak
to this measure
not seeing any hands I would ask Madam
clerk to call the role on uh H C our 10
supporting statehood for the District of
Columbia
they say HR uh HR 10 uh yes sporting
state of District of Columbia the motion
is itl
Rollins
yes Lundgren yes roulette yes
anchorberger votes yes
McDonald's yes
Cagney yes kamanti
yes
Binny
it's a tough one
yes
Manion yes
shirtless no massmilla
Carrie no
Morton no
Smith
no
Lamontagne
O'Neill
and seabird
and the chair
yes
so 10 years and eight Nays
ten years eight Nays supporting the itl
motion and that was made by
representative pimonte representative
pimonte will get together on a on a
committee report and would someone care
to make a alternative report
and
at this time I see no one at this time
stepping up for that so we will now move
on to HR 13.
the title is affirming support for the
people of Puerto Rico
representative Charlotte do you uh
have an interest in Emotion in this or
do you know someone who might
be
I'd be very glad to move out a pass
motion by representative shurtleff OTP
seconded by representative gagne
representative Charlotte would you care
to speak to your emotion just briefly uh
we had some wonderful uh testimony
including the friend that's with us
today from Laconia and the fact that
Puerto Rico has been part of the United
States since the Spanish-American War
the United States wanted it to provide
coal for ships going through the Panama
Canal and for the defensive reasons and
the fact that the
the Commonwealth has not been able to
self-determine its own future
um I think this idea of not allowing
them to have a public site to vote
statehood uh Independence or the main
part of a commonwealth with with the
mainland us is a shame and it's
something I know that's very passionate
among the people of Puerto Rico it's
actually divisive in elections for
governor and for their representative uh
in Washington uh but I think it's they
should be able to self-determine the
future of that Island
it is not 1898 it's now 2023 and we
should act accordingly thank you Mr
chair
thank you representative Sherlock
representative Gaffney would you care to
speak to your second
oh the representative has done a good
job
would anyone else care to speak to this
measure
the motion is OTP
I'll say one thing I said this during
the previous hearing my college roommate
Jose Enrique Casado is Puerto Rican and
if this passes I think it
I have a feeling it might I will have to
queue up the YouTube and send him a link
that said uh last call for comment
seeing none uh Madam chair if you would
read the role for the motion of
OTP for HR 13 affirming support for the
people of Puerto Rico
ones yes Lundgren
not here oh could you step out
um roulette yes
ankerberger votes yes
McDonald's yes
gag me yes he Monty yes
Vinnie yes Manion yes shirtless yes
masmilla
Carrie yes Morton yes
uh Smith yes
LaMontagne yes O'Neill
seabird yeah
just checking my account first chair
Rose yes
so 17
. and without objection I think Madam
chair we can put that on the consent
calendar
now there are only two so far that going
on consent correct
so far so far okay that brings us to uh
back to HB 269 no we have five other
measures that we heard this morning and
I I don't I haven't had a chance to talk
to the uh ranking member about any of
them I don't see us representative of
the five we heard this morning I think
we need time to process
I would agree with the chair on that so
that leaves us just one bill then and
that's HB 269 we have an amendment to it
is is there anyone who does not have a
copy of the amendment
so I what I would like to do here uh
here's the situation with HB 269 uh
relative to The Authority of New
Hampshire delegates to
uh to be sent to policy making
conventions that's very much related I
think to HB 392 which we're going to
exec next Friday week from today
relative to Constitutional Convention
procedures for delegates now one of the
reasons uh and not everybody was here
all day for the uh for the earlier
testimony
on HB 392 but it was pointed out that
these that these two measures are are
similar
and the question came up is would is
there conflict between the language
between the two measures where in other
words if if one were to pass would it
negate the other one or vice versa
which accounts for this amendment being
worked up so what I would like to do
what I what I'm going to do is I'm going
to
push off the exact session on HB 269 to
give everyone a chance to review the
amendment
as well as review both of these measures
in in their entirety as they they are
related and then we will finish taking
that up uh next Friday the 10th and we
we do the last of our
our executive session
um
measures is there any question on that
or on anything else
uh representative Smith
this is just a procedural question
um
uh am I incorrect in saying that after
the hearing and in an executive session
the amendment would have to be brought
forward by a member of the committee
right yes the question has to do with
the amen being introduced by a member of
the committee and I believe that was
representative Finney are you the one
that that
put forth the amendment
um representative Reed's name is on
there but I didn't I didn't put forth
the amendment but I was just the
okay because uh representative Reed
that's a good procedural point I my
understanding was that representative
Finney for the committee uh and against
you know substitutes uh in non-committee
members cannot introduce amendments so
this was passed out it does have
representative Reed's name on it uh so I
think I know that for this to be to
follow protocol it needs to be
introduced by Committee Member such as
yourself if if you're willing to uh get
with OLS and and have your name in the
top of this uh
um the only issue is that because of my
work commitments I can't be here on the
10th anyway
right and you've already uh alerted me
to that
um so let me ask is there someone else
represent Manning okay you you will I'm
good to go you will be here next Friday
I'll be here
so if you could get with OLS make sure
your name is on on the uh amending uh
the amendment it's currently uh
zero three three zero H the amendment so
good thank you so we'll get your name on
that we'll have we'll speak to that next
Friday
and anything else from anyone on
anything
if not it's uh 1500 hours it's cold out
getting colder uh safe travels and we'll
we'll see all of you okay represent menu
where are we going to do hdr5
uh
HCR 5
uh it was a fossil fuel lawsuit
just not sure
let me just
foreign
is published uh did not have hcr5 uh oh
as you were yes uh thank you represent
that this that is one that we did have a
hearing on and that's one that we thank
you uh somehow my eyes passed over that
yes we should do and we'll do hdr5 right
now
okay
hdr5 involved
urging the appropriate legal action
against multinational fossil fuel
companies for harms incurred from
disinformation
thank you representative uh Manion
um and thanks for bringing do you have a
motion yeah some emotions itl
you have a second
uh representative Rollins seconded that
Madam chair so motion is on hcr5 with
regard to legal action against
multinational fossil fuel companies
and uh
motion by representative Manion seconded
by representative Rollins representative
Manny would you care to speak to your
motion uh the when we were doing our
exact session we got down into like the
weeds that was talking a lot about um
it's valid uh concerns about foreign
companies that also
a foreign countries not just companies
that have these uh energy policies that
would just not be kept in in check so we
are here uh shooting ourselves in the
face while the rest of the country uh
Planet gets to continue on with economic
development
foreign
is the secondary would you care to speak
to your your seconding motion
I'll just agree with the representative
over there or something I was going to
say but it's not that important so I'm
all set
thank you representative uh who else
would like to speak to this measure
representative O'Neill
um yes I just wanted to say having
having studied that length um in law
school the history of the tobacco
industry
um this is how change gets made um this
is how it gets done and it's it was true
with the opioid crisis as well and I
think this is the appropriate action
that needs to be taken you know we can
only control what's what's within our
own borders but that doesn't mean we do
nothing
thank you representative representative
Charlotte
thank you Mr chairman um yeah I'll be
voting against the motion I think when
we see Rochelle came out with 40 billion
dollars the other day in profits a lot
of them those profits been made by
misinformation to the general public I
think the biggest one is what we've
learned now with the oil companies have
said about uh climate change that in the
public who was all the fast can we find
out they were more accurate when they
their internal predictions was it's far
worse than even the government was
predicting so think of things like that
there should be some uh method
methodology if they have them pay for
their past ends and I'll be voting
against the uh the motion thank you Mr
chairman
thank you representative shurliff other
comments representative Lamontagne
yes it seems to me as we some of us had
already have stated we need to invest in
the future we need to invest in a green
uh infrastructure and this would be one
way to do it without having the
taxpayers with the bill let's put some
of the responsibility back on the
industry that has caused so much harm
thank you representative LaMontagne
other hands other comments
seeing none the emotion on the floor is
to is an itl motion on hcr5
which urges The Taking of appropriate
legal action against multinational
fossil fuel companies for harms incurred
from disinformation campaigns about the
effects of fossil fuel combustion
Madam chair when you're ready
Rollins
yes Lundgren yes
roulette yes anchorberg anchorberg vote
Yes
McDonald's yes gagne yes hey Monty
yes
Vinnie yes Manion yes
shirtless no massmella no
Carrie no
Morton no
Marjorie Smith no
Lamontagne
O'Neill
Siebert
chair
yes
ten to eight
okay once again representative Manion I
know you you've made a lot of motions
today we'll work
we'll work on the uh the report is there
uh alternative report
in the works
not seeing any for this resolution
uh we'll have the at least the one
report
and
okay representative Siebert will uh and
if you can get that to me Monday
by email it by Monday
and then we'll get that to the house
clerk thank you
okay I think that's everything that
thanks for catching that represent
Manion we don't want to um
not get that done when we could get that
done today so we have five measures plus
HB 269 next Friday and that will uh
we'll do it for uh for this committee
for at least until crossover
um
if no
yes uh 10 o'clock uh 10 1000 hours next
week in this room and uh and thank you
to the subs for showing up on this uh
on this record speaking of uh the
climate on this record cold day yes
and at this at that time we will uh
adjourn thank you thank you thank you
Mr chair
foreign